c'est un travail dangereux oui même les
enfants travaillent pour en extraire et
ses parents et ça c'est kalyan à moto
[Musique]
frotter votre main de virac
c'est pourtant leur seul moyen de survie
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi l'essentiel de l'information
avec nos invités en plateau et nos
reporters sur le terrain voici les
grands titres de l'actualité de ce
mercredi 22 janvier le liban fait face à
une catastrophe avertit le nouveau
premier ministre qui promet de répondre
aux défis zim des finances qui attendent
le nouveau gouvernement loin de
satisfaire les libanais des paroles qui
n'apaise pas la colère de la rue
beyrouth est actuellement en proie à d
ailleurs j moins un avant le forum de la
shoah 40 dirigeants sont à jérusalem
parmi les présidents russe allemand et
français
après s'être entendu entretenu avec le
premier ministre israélien emmanuel
macron rencontre les dirigeants
palestiniens selon lui la négation de
l'existence d'israël comme état tient de
l'antisémitisme
[Musique]
vers un code de la liberté de la presse
pour la police le centre européen pour
la liberté de la presse et des médias et
le syndicat national des journalistes
cgt s'associent et lancent ensemble
depuis paris un code à destination des
forces de l'ordre un code qui intervient
au moment où des journalistes français
ont été victimes de violences policières
pendant les manifestations des dernières
semaines
reprise ce soir à washington du procès
en destitution de données entre le sénat
entame les débats de fond
le président américain en déplacement au
forum économique de davos en suisse
étapes sont même si je cite il adore
vrai y être il est accusé par le camp
démocrate d'abus de pouvoir et d'entravé
à la bonne marche du congrès
l'événement
nouvelle manifestation anti système en
ce début de soirée au liban après trois
mois de crise le pays a depuis hier un
nouveau gouvernement validée par le
président michel aoun est dirigé par le
premier ministre hassan diab
mais les libanais qui peinent à être
convaincus ont à nouveau manifesté dans
les rues de beyrouth les précisions de
série élevé david hess bellevue liant la
contestation perdure dans plusieurs
villes du pays après l annonce du
nouveau gouvernement libanais ce mardi
les manifestants dénoncent les ministres
fraîchement désigné comme appartenant au
même parti que ceux du gouvernement
précédent le nouveau premier ministre
hassan diab universitaire et ancien
ministre de l'éducation a dû tenir sa
première réunion ce mercredi matin
avertissant que son pays au bord de la
faillite faisait face à une catastrophe
selon une déclaration lue par un haut
fonctionnaire
nous sommes face à une impasse
financière économique et sociale
en réalité nous sommes face à une
catastrophe et nous devons alléger
l'impact et les répercussions de cette
catastrophe sur les libanais sa
description du problème peut nous
prendre beaucoup de temps maintenant
mais les intitulés des problèmes sont
claires et je suis sûr que chacun
d'entre vous comprend l'ampleur des
risques des groupes de manifestants ont
barré les rues avec des pneus en feu
dans plusieurs quartiers de beyrouth
détente brûler des manifestants
repoussés par les forces de l'ordre avec
des canons à eau et des gaz lacrymogènes
des scènes de guérilla urbaine preuve de
la détermination de la rue en tant que
manifestants si le gouvernement donne le
coup d'envoi nous resteront
définitivement dans la rue et il y aura
certainement une escalade car nous ne
pouvons pas nous laisser faire face à
cette situation la famine frappe aux
portes de tous nos livres la pauvreté et
la crise financière la suisse a traversé
tous pays nous nous mobiliserons de plus
en plus dans que le gouvernement ne nous
écoutera pas le liban connaît une des
pires crises socio économique et
financière depuis la fin de la guerre
civile en 1990 depuis le 17 octobre
dernier
l'ensemble de la classe dirigeante est
accusé de corruption et d'incompétence
des attaques qui avaient poussé l'ex
premier ministre saad hariri a
démissionné et pour en parler nous
sommes avec paula 1re et des activistes
et membre du mouvement beyrouth madinaty
bonsoir paula rebes merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france à sanaa
diable qui s'était donc engagée à
choisir des technocrates indépendants
est ce le cas pour ce nouveau cabinet
qui a pas l'air de plaire beaucoup aux
libanais pour le moment ce nouveau
cabinet a été formée d'une manière
complètement égoïste on va dire ils ont
fait ce cabinet pour faire plaisir à
leurs propres partis ils ont exclu
certains partis et ils ont exclu les
demandes de la rue ils ont complètement
fait fi de la rue c'est presque un défi
pour nous alors vous dites les ont ils
n'ont pas du tout écouter les demandes
de la rue il n'empêche qu'il ya quand
même des membres de ce nouveau cabinet
qui sont plutôt indépendant et
réformateur ce n'est pas votre analyse
ya tout à jeter là dedans ce n'est pas
question de jeter ou ne pas jeter ce
sont des gens qui ont un bon parcours
académique dont la plupart un bon
bako a admis mais ils appartiennent que
ce soit politiquement
même s'ils disent qu'ils sont
indépendants ce n'est pas du tout le cas
ils sont soit conseillers soient amis
soit le mari de quelqu'un qui fait
partie d'un parti politique de cette
couleur précise comment ça se fait alors
qu' il ya des manifestations qu'on
connaît qui sont immenses un
mécontentement qui est très tenace au
liban que le nouveau gouvernement ait
pris ce risque aujourd'hui est ce que
vous vous l'expliquer ils ont ils sont
obligés vis-à-vis de la communauté
internationale et du peuple libanais de
d'avancé un petit peu mais je ne sais
pas ce qu'il apprend de penser que le
peuple est satisfait vous voyez bien
vous voyez vous même les images que vous
avez filmé c'est insoutenable
ils sont en train d'attaquer les gens
les manifestants d'une manière qui ne
n'a rien à voir avec les droits de
l'homme il ya des distances pour les
balles en caoutchouc qui sont de 35
mètres minimum ils sont en train de
tirer à trois mètres nous avons plus de
500 blessés depuis le week-end je dis
nous je parle de tout le peuple libanais
que ce soit forces de l'ordre aux
manifestants
le peuple a faim le peuple n'a pas les
moyens de payer son loyer nous voyons de
plus en plus de familles descendre
habiter dans la rue ils peuvent pas
payer les écoles ce n'est pas un
gouvernement d'une seule coalition qui
va pouvoir régler cette crise est là par
exemple vous écoute vous écoutez les
aînés je vous en prie par exemple nous
pensons que le ministre de la justice
qui a affilié à un certain parti qui a
été choisie par un certain parti comment
va-t-il pouvoir juger c'est même parti
en étant c'est impossible il peut pas
les juger
ils peuvent pas du tout être comment va
dire neutre dès qu'ils vont commencer à
faire par exemple la lutte contre la
corruption
va-t-il lutter contre les sa propre
famille politique ou ses propres frères
soeurs marie je sais pas mais personne
n'est dupe
quelle que soit la stratégie nous savons
très bien qu'elle ne fera qu implémenter
leurs idées alors une partie a
effectivement de l'opposition est
clairement rester en dehors des
tractations de
ce nouveau cabinet comment le
gouvernement peut désormais composer
avec cette opposition selon vous déjà le
fait qu'ils les ont mis dehors ça veut
dire qu'ils veulent pas composer avec
eux pour nous pour moi et pour la
majorité du peuple c'est un gouvernement
mort né on va voir combien de temps ils
vont durer à sanaa diab a soutenu par le
hezbollah quand on sait que le hezbollah
y très mal vues par une partie de la
communauté internationale est ce qu'à un
risque pour vous de voir le liban est
relâché par certains pays c'est
peut-être là le point d'achoppement le
point très compliqué finalement négocié
entre ce gouvernement libanais et le
peuple
oui parce que ce gouvernement n'aura pas
la bienveillance international vue sur
la filiation comme vous venez de le dire
ces pros et rend donc je ne vois pas
comment un gouvernement de n'importe
quel pays peut nous soutenir nous avons
besoin d'être soutenus parce que vous
voyez bien que le peuple ne supporte
plus après 30 ans d'être gérés par ces
partis là le peuple n'arrive plus à
accepter les partis politiques ils
veulent des gens vraiment indépendant
pas d'élire le mode et techno
actionnaires parce que cela ce sont des
indépendants en apparence mais nous
voyons tous très bien que selon l'oncle
de l'ain et invoqua d'un certain parti
politique
la deuxième est la femme de deux parties
d'un membre d'un parti politique c'est
vraiment pathétique voilà à l' homo que
je trouve c'est est ce qu'il ya des
personnalités aujourd'hui à même de se
présenter qui se sont fait connaître
auprès de ce gouvernement parce que
c'est vrai que je me fais présentement
l'avocat du diable mais quand on cherche
à recruter évidemment on le fait dans
son entourage peut-être peut-être avec
un peu trop de facilité on prend les
gens effectivement qu'on que l'on
connaît est ce que ces personnalités là
aujourd'hui elles sont identifiées par
le pape parce qu'on sait aussi que ce
peuple est très divisée holy manque
peut-être est là toute la complication
alors nous avons eu la chance d'avoir un
bateau ni qui a été élu indépendant qui
s'appelle mais le n 4 à la ce qui
représente
il s'est vraiment un consensus dans le
peuple ibère le peuple libanais il aime
beaucoup
tout le monde le respecte tous les
membres de tous les paliers pour qu'il
peut aller partis politiques le respect
et nous avons un membre en fait ce n'est
pas le monde c'est quelqu'un dans la
communauté internationale qui s'appelle
nawaf salam qui représente vraiment les
demandes de la rue la moitié des gens
que l'on va dire parce que le peuple on
ne peut pas dire tout le peuple
on va être obligé de dire que la moitié
du peuple le respecte et aimerait bien
qu'ils soient qu'ils fassent partie d'un
gouvernement vraiment indépendant
justement pas au lard et bête est ce que
ce n'est pas là tout le problème nous
dit pas tout le peuple à moitié puisque
on sait que le peuple libanais voilà une
composante extrêmement variée est ce que
ce n'est pas l'art je réitère ma
question qu est finalement le plus gros
problème à trouver un gouvernement qui
puisse satisfaire la majorité faire
taire les mécontentements
en fait je vous dis la moitié parce que
vous savez très bien qu'il ya une autre
moitié qui n'ose pas vraiment encore
s'exprimer
donc cet autre moitié de soutien souvent
ils passaient nous passe des mots ils
nous disent continuer mais il n'ose pas
descendre dans la rue vu leur
affiliation politique
et là de plus en plus on les voit
descendre avec nous ces fameuses autre
moitié
mais si on arrive à avoir un
gouvernement de gens propres et
indépendance c'est le rêve et j'espère
ce sera pas seulement un art que ce sera
très bientôt une réalité pour nous
aujourd'hui clairement pas au lard et
bêtes que demande le peuple on a compris
que le peuple avait faim que le peuple
était en colère mais quelles sont
vraiment les deux trois demandes
concrètes qui ferait taire cette colère
qui semble ne jamais s'arrêter et
s'intensifier au contraire cela ne fait
que trois mois je dirais mais pour
certains ces trois mois de trop mais
c'est quand même trois mois où les gens
n'ont pas arrêté d'être dans la rue même
si la communauté internationale et la
presse internationale n'a pas présenter
cela au monde mais nous ça fait plus de
95 jours qu'on est dans la rue et nous
ne baisserons pas les bras nous
continuerons pas ce que nous voulons
gouvernement indépendant nous voulons
surtout la l'indépendance de la machine
judiciaire parce que c'est le seul moyen
de régler le sort des corrompus parce
que vous savez très bien que ça fait 30
ans que la recul corruption gangrène le
pays
rien ne peut être fait sans corrompre
quelqu'un sans donner un barchiche comme
on dit c'est c'est vraiment vous voyez à
tous les niveaux que ce soit faire un
papier dans un ministère ou à la mairie
ou bien au niveau de l'état pour acheter
de du mazout et du gaz pour le quotidien
du peuple
c'est quand même incroyable c'est pas
une république bananière c'est encore
plus que ça c'est un république
agriculture bananière merci beaucoup en
tout cas pas au lard et bête ça d'avoir
été avec nous en direct depuis le liban
de nous avoir apporté votre analyse
merci à vous place demain au 5ème forum
mondial sur l'antisémitisme jérusalem de
nombreux dirigeants internationaux se
réunissent pour commémorer les 75 ans de
la libération du camp d'auschwitz
l'événement aura lieu au mémorial de yad
vashem où thomas bonnet s'est rendu sur
place avec stéphanie joie la presse
israélienne est unanime il s'agit du
plus grand événement diplomatique jamais
organisé ici d'ailleurs les
organisateurs sont très agréablement
surpris agréablement surpris par la
forte présence de délégations
internationales elles sont au nombre de
49 49 délégations internationales réunis
ici à jérusalem pour ce 5e forum mondial
de l'eau low cost qui commémore cette
année les 75 ans de la libération du
camp d'auschwitz c'était en janvier 1945
ce jeudi 23 janvier
plusieurs leaders internationaux vont
prendre la parole il s'agit des
représentants des vainqueurs de la
seconde guerre mondiale un cycle de
l'allemagne le pays qui a perpétré la
shoah et cela nous mène à notre première
polémique l'absence du président
polonais ici le président polonais qui
avait souhaité prendre la parole cela
n'a donc pas été possible et c'est ce
qui explique son absence on rappelle que
la pologne était le pays dans lequel
était basé le camp d'auschwitz l'autre
polémique qui met ici c'est la faible
présence des survivants de l'holocauste
ils sont seulement une transe
ten avoir été invité à cette
commémoration
[Musique]
oubliez ces débats d'ordre
organisationnel quand on entre ici dans
le mémorial de yad vashem à jérusalem
un mémorial composés d'énormément de
documents de témoignages et d'objets
ayant appartenu aux juifs exterminés
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale les
dirigeants internationaux qui font le
déplacement vont évidemment pouvoir
observer ces documents exceptionnels
cela permettra de se remémorer l'horreur
de la shoah mais également de combattre
l'antisémitisme moderne
c'est d'ailleurs tout sauf un hasard si
le titre de ce 5e forum mondial de
l'holocauste et celui ci se remémorer le
low cost combattre l'antisémitisme
[Musique]
la réunion de tous ses dirigeants pour
cet événement international intervient
dans un contexte particulier à plus d'un
titre d'abord il existe un différend
entre moscou et varsovie en décembre
dernier vladimir poutine a accusé la
pologne d'avoir collaboré avec
l'allemagne nazie pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale plus généralement le
président russe reproche à un certain
nombre de pays de minorer si ce n'est
d'occulter le rôle de l'union soviétique
contre l'allemagne nazie
l'autre contexte à prendre en
considération c'est l'actualité
internationale
il ya d'abord le dossier iranien qui
menace la stabilité régionale et qui
préoccupe particulièrement le
gouvernement israélien l'autre point
c'est le processus de paix au proche
orient un processus toujours à l'arrêt
depuis maintenant de longs mois et puis
il ya la situation politique en israël
où des élections législatives auront
lieu au mois de mars les troisièmes
élections législatives en un an pour ce
pays qui peine à former un gouvernement
tous ces sujets devrait être abordée
lors des entretiens bilatéraux qui vont
avoir lieu en marge de ce 5e forum
mondial de l'holocauste et qui ne font
que renforcer l'importance de cet
événement est alors qu'emmanuel mais
comment était attendu à la basilique
sainte anne à jérusalem les services de
sécurité français et israéliens se sont
disputés à l'entrée du monument une
altercation brutale à laquelle le chef
de l'état a pris par aymen uniquement
ainsi exigé le départ de policiers
israéliens de l'église sainte-anne
propriété de la france depuis le 19e
siècle
une scène qui rappelle évidemment un
célèbre incident qui avait impliqué
jacques chirac dans les années 1990
écouter justement l'explication qu'on a
donnée le président français arrivons à
sainte anne qui est un domaine français
et l'injure qui était assez classique il
ya eu un moment de d'énervement entre
les équipes de sécurité et il me
revenait il mettre bon ordre
on réexplique mans quelles sont les
règles depuis que la france a ainsi
quelques domaines il c'est vrai pour
sainte-anne la sécurité israélienne qui
a fait un travail formidable mais côté
dans les rues et tout a été très calme
elle s'arrête aux portes de sainte anne
c'est la sécurité française qui prend le
relais et pertinent pour sa jacques
chirac je n'aurais pas dit c'était
prémédité un prêt non pas du tout parce
que je pensais que ça se passerait bien
mais c'est vous qui le faites maintenant
non non non c'était pas mais pas de
préméditation parce que je pensais que
ça se passerait bien
c'est un peu le jeu et la parenthèse a
été a été refermé conservatoire et non
mes potes non parce qu'on n'a pas eue
regarder le 17 août après j'ai salué les
demandes de sécurité on s'est serré la
main a chaleureusement les shows de
toubib voilà il ya parfois il ya des
moments où on cherche la bonne limite si
beaucoup de choses sont des histoires de
frontières vous savez parfois de limiter
donc il faut jamais les limites ne
soient franchies et on peut se le dire
même quand il ya des
le ton qui monte avec beaucoup d'amis
qui donc la parenthèse est fermé et au
delà du forum de la shoah cette visite
emmanuel macron en israël masque
plusieurs enjeux c'est l'avis du
géopolitologue jean christophe gaillard
je vous propose de l'écouter c'est sûr
que dans cette visite il ya des volets
veulent adresser at on parlera après un
volet régional et international et
national qui est celui déclaré
finalement en tout cas dire sa voix sur
sa version des choses sur ce qui est un
enjeu aujourd'hui renaissants
semble-t-il en fait un rallye terre une
vers une montée une remontée de
l'antisémitisme ressenti en tout cas
parler par les français de confession
juive
je crois qu'il clarifie finalement une
position comme il l'est clarifiant non
on en parlait à l'instant sur la
remontée regrettable en france d'un
certain nombre d'événements et clarifie
sa position ce niveau régional et
international
effectivement il a une position qui est
encore une fois très différente de celle
de donald trump très différente de celle
de wailly route il donc des grands
leaders de la planète en ce cas de blocs
à bloc et il veut essayer de faire
valoir une position intermédiaire de la
france sur un ensemble de sujets donc je
crois que c'est plus une
encore une fois une précision d'une
position diplomatique française jusqu'à
présent et les mots en un sens les mots
sont forts on voit bien que là en
l'occurrence il s'agit quand même de
dire des choses assez fort adressé cette
fois-ci non pas aux français de
confession encore une fois jugé mais
véritablement aux israéliens et on voit
qu'en israël d'ailleurs là la position
de la france est un peu à peu compris
esther qu'on voit qu'on n'est pas les
plus populaires encore une fois très
loin en tout cas lui qui incarne la
france est très loin d'être aussi
populaire que donald trump par exemple
en ce moment donc on voit aussi qu'il ya
un enjeu
je dirais diplomatique mais diplomatie
publique au monde y est aussi adressé
aux israéliens il
il a précisé il l'a dit l'a pas dit que
c'était la critique de l'état il a dit
la critique des positions des
gouvernements en tout cas de la position
d'israël et des représentants d'israël
entame du gouvernement leurs positions
politiques ou géopolitiques
évidemment peuvent être contestées comme
n'importe quelle position dans un autre
état et là ya vraiment une différence
notable
là où il affirme quand même quelque
chose c'est dire qu'on voudrait effacer
l'état d'israël de la carte géopolitique
et donc des pays des nations de cette
planète là pour le coup c'est là où il
dit que c'est une affaire d'anti
sémitisme et qui savaient plus
simplement de l'antisionisme il ya trois
situations d'une situation on va plus
exactement trois situations exactement
la situation propre à israël où il ya
une crise politique mais qu'israël
connaît continue de son système
électoral proportionnel intégral
les gouvernements sont des sondés et
d'association et donc c'est compliqué
parfois de créer associations et
notamment la personnalité de monsieur
netanyahou aujourd'hui et très qu'il
vente
donc il ya un enjeu israélien interne y
est un enjeu régional où la france là
pour le coup est impliqué sur longeau
syrien selon le jo iranien sur la
relation entre les l'iran l'arabie
saoudite mais aussi israël évidemment et
c'est enjeu régional l'a fait résonner
notamment à travers l'implication de la
france aux côtés des chrétiens d'orient
où il vient dire que des moyens seront
soulevées par ce que notamment en termes
d'éducation en termes de soutien la
langue française
et ça c'est très important parce que on
voit bien qu'il ya une idée de lady mais
aussi françaises qui s'affirme dans
cette zone a bis et l'enjeu
international où la france et l'europe
veulent faire entendre leur voix dans un
contexte où l'enjeu moyen-orientale
et quand même dominé aujourd'hui par les
prises de positions à la fois de
monsieur trump et de monsieur poutine
notamment en tout cas de la russie et
des états unis avec une dimension
iranienne qui est important donc il ya
les trois dimensions la ou encore une
fois la france d'en faire entendre sa
voix à la fois diplomatique d'action
peser sur les actions et serait dans
toronto ne sais pas c'est évidemment que
c'est impossible et que ce n'est pas
l'enjeu d'un pays étranger mais sur les
deux autres aspects qui sont encore une
fois l'enjeu régional à françois prendre
la partie sa main et l'enjeu
international où l'europe avec la france
voudrait dire sur nombre de vérités ou
ensemble de points qui sont les leurs la
voix de la france
en tout cas elle tente de compte et la
voix de l'europe est aussi temps de
s'affirmer comme unifié ce qui est pas
simple l'adp sur cette question là
encore une fois on est dans un dossier
qui est mixte qui est à la fois un
dossier presque interne entre les deux
pays ont bien que certains disent il
faut un seul pays vous l'avez bien un
seul ou deux pays très sévère
aujourd'hui on est dans cette situation
là même temps israël et certains pays
arabes ont finalement fait associations
sur le dossier on voit bien que c'est
nathalie baye les signes on était un peu
abandonnés par leur leurs voisins
du monde arabe donc c'est un sujet
complexe là où finalement les grandes
puissances
encore une fois que sont les etats-unis
la russie l'iran régionalement la chine
qui est un peu loin qu'il peut tout à
fait forcément mais en tout cas on voit
bien que le contexte n'est pas favorable
aujourd'hui un règlement rapide parce
que on est dans l'incertitude de quelque
chose qui se déplaçait plus tôt encore
une fois en termes d'intensité de crise
entre l'iran la syrie l'irak et l'arabie
saoudite tourner dans cette zone là
israël et palestine c'est pas très loin
mais c'est pas j'irai sur le dessus de
la table aujourd'hui c'est pas le
premier dossier est exactement mais qui
malheureusement est malheureusement et
pour eux en tout cas est un petit peu a
rétrogradé dans l échelle les dossiers
les plus importants ce qui est ce qui
est assez là aussi intéressant c'est
encore une fois le débat qui a lieu en
israël sur cette question là qui en a
qui est agité évidemment par des forces
extérieures mais aussi parce qu'à
l'intérieur il ya aussi un grand débat
démocratique autour de cette question
la solution le jus de la solution le vue
politique la solution viendrait pas
facile à trouver encore en italie luigi
di maio démissionne du mouvement 5
étoiles qu'il présidait annonce faite
cet après midi lors d'un rassemblement
de membres du mouvement
cette décision intervient juste avant
une élection régionale cruciale prévue
dimanche dans le nord est du pays
une victoire de l'extrême droite
pourrait entraîner la chute du
gouvernement formé par le mouvement 5
étoiles le parti démocrate
on écoute
je suis ici aujourd'hui pour donner ma
démission en tant que leader du
mouvement 5 étoiles et ouvrir la route
vers le congrès du parti
beaucoup d'entre vous m'écrivent et
m'appellent pour me dire de ne pas
abandonner
je n'abandonne pas
en ce qui me concerne ce n'est que la
fin d'une phase et nous nous reverrons
au congrès du parti
nous pourrons échanger des idées je
serai là pour l'italie et pour tous ceux
qui ont besoin d aide
je serai là et je n'abandonnerai pas
pour ma part je continuerai à servir les
italiens et le mouvement 5 étoiles en
faisant le plus d'efforts possibles
entre autres choses nous avons un
référendum constitutionnel en mai un
autre objectif que nous avons atteint
[Applaudissements]
pour moi et pour vous une nouvelle
saison va commencer à partir de ce soir
où rôle de chef de parti cessera je vous
remercie
avec nous dans quelques instants un nous
recevrons notre invité politique ce soir
julien odoul président du groupe
rassemblement national au conseil
régional de bourgogne franche comté
candidat à la mairie de sens
et puis nous parlerons du lancement en
vain codes de la liberté de la presse
pour la police alors que les accusations
de violences policières se multiplient
rester avec nous
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici seul interdit d'interdire
ma passion c'est les chiens nordiques je
dirais donc le chien de race husky de
sibérie qu'est ce qu'ils représentent
pour vous ces chiens un meilleur
présente plein de choses parce que c'est
de l'amour de l'amour au quotidien je
chassais point de motoneige ainsi pas
une machine c'est pour vous faire
plaisir bien souvent du coup chaque
chine a son caractère
il ya certaines de mes chiennes avec
truqué leur reviennent par le regard on
arrive à se comprendre
cette année on a fait un parcours à
l'envers arrivé à un moment
depuis des années on prend à gauche
cette année nous a fait prendre la piste
par la droite au fait comment alors
la chienne de tête assez retourner elle
m'a dit tu es sur ton coup parce que
c'est pas par là qu'il faut aller c'est
d'autre côté
[Musique]
les news ne s'arrête jamais mais c'est
votre soutien que nous apprécions le
plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent là l on
soit vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui une gauche extrême tous les
témoins de notre époque sont dans la
grande interview
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai fort potentiel programme moi et je
ferai que ce que tu veux toi tu es un
robot nous on est des êtres humains
je vous emmène découvrir les robots les
plus high tech qui vont bientôt sortir
de leur laboratoire pour rentrer dans
nos maisons
[Musique]
walker ambac l'ère des robots approche
nous avons l'opportunité de pouvoir
changer le monde
ceux-ci excitant ils vont changer notre
manière de nous divertir d'apprendre le
communiqué en fait il y avait changé
notre vie
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes c'est diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
20h30 heure française merci nous
rejoindre en direct sur rt france le
trafic à la ratp et à la sncf a été
quasiment normal pour la première fois
depuis 46 jours ce mercredi mais la
contestation contre la réforme des
retraites elle se poursuit malgré tout à
deux jours de la grande mobilisation
attendue vendredi
plusieurs opérations ont eu lieu à
travers tout le pays ont fait le point
avec guillemard aussi one 7 heures du
matin un rassemblement organisé par
l'intersyndicale tourner court
une centaine de manifestants tentent de
mettre en place un barrage filtrant dans
le cadre d'une opération ville morte
délogés par les forces de l'ordre ils se
dirigent ensuite vers la préfecture
une nouvelle action est prévue ce jeudi
plus au nord la grève des salariés de la
centrale nucléaire de gravelines près de
dunkerque se poursuit ces derniers ont
reçu la visite du secrétaire général de
la cgt philippe martinez venus re
motiver les agents qui depuis près de
deux semaines filtrent les entrées du
site
s'il fallait une démonstration ce cette
lutte
cette mobilisation elle est massive et
populaire vous en fait la démonstration
par le nombre qui est rassemblée ici et
par ce qui se passe dans cette centrale
vous le savez le gouvernement essaye de
nous dire que cette réforme est juste et
simple elle est tellement elle est
tellement simple que personne n'y
comprend rien elle est tellement juste
qu'il ya des milliers et dizaines de
milliers de salariés qui sont en grains
dans ce pays et que plus de 60% de
l'opinion publique soutient massivement
mais mouvant gravel mouvement social qui
est en cours depuis le 5 décembre les
dernières la cgt qui a relancé ce
mercredi l'opération port mort au havre
mais aussi dans la cité phocéenne
le grand port de marseille connaît
régulièrement des blocages depuis le
mois de décembre
seul moyen de se faire entendre selon
les agents portuaires et d'obtenir le
retrait du projet de réforme
le patronat doit aujourd'hui prendre
conscience qu'on se rattrapa et qu'on
continuera et que les impacts
aujourd'hui l'économie qu'il mesure bien
évidemment on allait confirmer on n'a
pas d'autre choix pour essayer d'être
entendu et c'est notre seul moyen
aujourd'hui de faire en sorte que le
gouvernement a bien revienne sur sa
décision avec ce projet de réforme des
retraites
enfin paris épicentre de la contestation
depuis le début du mouvement
outre un rassemblement de salariés du
commerce et des services devant la gare
saint lazare les égoutiers sont venus
exprimer leur mécontentement au pied du
ministère des finances à bercy
selon eux la réforme supprimerait les
avantages liés à la pénibilité de leur
profession
repoussant de dix ans leur départ en
retraite donc on a choisi le ministère
de l'économie et des finances
aujourd'hui pour montrer les victimes de
la réforme des retraites à savoir les
égoutiers avec la fin de la catégorie
active et de nos de notre statut
aujourd'hui avec l'espérance de vie 17
ans réduite qu'on les égoutiers on
partira à la retraite et on sera mort
quotidiennement un égoutier l'exposer à
des insectes
à deraa des tout ce que vous pouvez les
pieds dans la merde quand vous tirez
votre chasse d'eau les équipiers pas de
danse on a retrouvé de l'amiante
maintenant a fait la santé notre dame à
tous et duplo bon quotidiennement un
égoutier l'exposé ça et maintenant on
nous dit quoi on dit aux gars ce système
maintenant c'est 60 de son ballon se
retrouve pas en édifier sait on à 10 58
ans des sports de vie des actions qui
doivent se poursuivre en cette fin de
semaine avec en point d'orgue une vaste
mobilisation prévue dans toute la france
vendredi à l'appel de l'intersyndicale
et pour décrypter l'actualité nous
sommes avec julien odoul président du
groupe rassemblement national au conseil
régional de bourgogne franche comté
candidat à la mairie de sens et notre
invité politique ce soit
bonsoir julien oms merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france on l'a
dit en début de cette tranche
d'information le trafic est normal
désormais est la ratp à la sncf d'une
certaine manière ça veut dire selon vous
que le gouvernement a d'une façon déjà
gagné non il n'a pas gagné puisque la
contestation perdure l opposition à
cette réforme des retraites qui ressenti
légitimement profondément injuste
continue on le voit dans toutes les
enquêtes d'opinion
les français ne veulent pas travailler
plus longtemps et vivre moins bien il
falloir que le gouvernement l'entende
que le président de la république
l'entendent également et retire ce
projet et arrête ces petits tours de
passe-passe et petites manipulations
on a vu avec le coût de la chp niveau
qui n'était qu'un âge pipeau on le voit
avec ce simulateur
donc il serait mis en oeuvre donc six
mois après donc l'instauration de la loi
donc tout ça évidemment est rejeté par
les français donc nous ce qu'on veut et
ce qu'ils appellent les français c'est
de la clarté c'est que le gouvernement
le président la république mettre ce
projet sur la table et pose la question
aux français par référendum qui serait
la seule manière de trancher
positivement ce sujet alors
effectivement plus de six français sur
dix 61% considèrent qu eminem là qu'on
devrait pas les contestations contre
cette réforme en compte et la retirer
une opinion hausse de quatre points en
un mois c'est important de le préciser
puisque la mobilisation effectivement ne
faiblit pas ce que vous avez le
sentiment que le gouvernement est parti
pour le retirer ce projet de loi vous y
croyez vraiment non je n'y crois pas
puisque ce gouvernement n'entend rien ce
gouvernement ne voit rien et ne comprend
rien ça fait quatorze mois puisque cette
opposition finalement s'inscrit aussi
dans la contestation et dans le
mouvement des idées jaune ça fait
quatorze mois que ce gouvernement jette
de l'huile sur le feu
finalement balaye les inquiétudes les
souffrances des français d'un revers de
main et surtout les plus graves at ease
les querelles puisque c'est ce qu'il
fait il l'a fait en jetant des gilets
jaunes contre des crs là il a jeté des
usagers des transports contre des
manifestants et des syndicalistes
aujourd'hui on a besoin d'apaisement on
a besoin de rassemblement on a besoin de
responsabilité et malheureusement c'est
pas avec ce gouvernement et ce président
de la république on le rend
effectivement l'apaisement n'est pas au
rendez vous deux syndicalistes agendés
nedis en dordogne ont été placés en
garde à vue dans le cadre d'une enquête
sur une coupure sauvage électricité
c'était il ya dix jours dans une
entreprise classée seveso philippe
martinez qui lie en jette de l'huile sur
le feu vous votre réaction
c'est quoi est-ce qu'il faut les
sanctionner ses agents il ya une forme
de colère légitime de colère saine pour
reprendre les mots de certaines il ya
surtout une forme de collaboration de
des leaders de la cgt avec le
gouvernement finalement qui partagent le
même projet de fracturation et de
divisions on le voit avec des
comportements totalement excessifs
illégaux avec ces coupures d'électricité
qui ne nuisent pas au gouvernement mais
concrètement qui nuisent aux français
donc la cgt est très mal placé
aujourd'hui pour défendre les intérêts à
la fois des salariés et puis des des
retraités il faut rappeler comme que la
cgt a voté pour le chaos social
ils on va appeler à voter pour amener le
maquereau philippe martinez a demandé à
ce qu'on fasse le score le plus haut
la cgt si on peut dire mais la cgt c'est
rouge devant et macron derrière donc à
un moment donné moi ce que je constate
c'est qu'ils sont les obligés des mails
macron ils font le jeu du gouvernement
en pourrissant la situation et en
essayant finalement de détourner la
mobilisation sincère de ce combat qui
légitime puisque tous les français
seront perdants avec ses tréfonds du
lien audio finalement c'est la cgt qui a
été la plus déterminée
la cfdt elle à négocier c'est d'ailleurs
ce que lui reprochent un sont entre
guillemets rival de la cgt d'ailleurs
quelle est votre réaction par rapport à
ces règlements de comptes entre
syndicats enfin la cgt qui s'est
introduit dans les locaux de la deuxième
franchement ça m'intéresse pas moi les
querelles entre syndicats
les petites bisbilles pour savoir
finalement qui va avoir le leadership
c'est pas très intéressants sont pas les
syndicalistes et ni les syndicats qui
tiennent aujourd'hui la concertation
sont les français sont les français qui
s'opposent massivement à cette réforme
si les syndicalistes était tout seul il
ne pourrait pas agir là ils sont
soutenus par une majorité de français
c'est pour ça que ça tient après
évidemment qu'on condamne toutes les
violences on sent qu'il ya quand même un
climat qui est extrêmement tendue qui
est extrêmement je dirais houleux mais
qui a alimenté d'une part par des nervis
par des excités de la cgt et d'autre
part dans le gouvernement par prisons de
la république aujourd'hui clairement
qu'elle doit prendre la forme de la
contestation il ya une nouvelle journée
de mobilisation nationale qui s'annonce
vendredi c'est la bonne solution
pourront vous continuer à manifester et
à faire grève c'est toujours ça qu'il
faut faire pour faire plier le
gouvernement et l'amener au référendum
que vous appelez de vos voeux
oui alors il ya divers moyens d'action
je pense que les avocats les avocats les
petits rats de l'opéra par des
mobilisations spectaculaire médiatique
jeu font énormément et pacifiquement
pour giresse opposés à cette réforme des
retraites
mais il ya surtout un moyen dont on
parle peu puisque le droit de grève
c'est bien mais le droit de vote c'est
encore mieux c'est beaucoup plus
efficace
donc c'est de manifester son
mécontentement son opposition dans les
urnes pour les municipales les 15 et 22
mars c'est le seul moyen pertinent et
efficace et je dirais extrêmement
percutant pour faire arrêter ce
gouvernement est pour lui montrer on est
contre cette réforme et on va le faire
savoir
mais vous au rassemblement national s'il
devait vous deviez être aux affaires
demain qu'est ce que vous feriez
justement avec cette réforme des
retraites parce que beaucoup de français
une majorité d'ailleurs s'accorde à dire
qu'elle est quand même nécessaire ils ne
sont pas d'accord avec cette réforme la
du gouvernement d'un cran mais il
s'accorde à dire qu'elle est quand même
nécessaire pour la viabilité
du système vous avez un plan précis
parce que le sentiment qu'il ya une
petite confusion
c'est très précis nous déjà on nous
disons que notre système de retraite est
viable voilà contrairement à ce que peut
dire le gouvernement il sera équilibré à
l'horizon 2035
alors le cas pas la même chose enfin en
tout cas des économistes le disent et
même temps il sera ici il sera il sera
équilibré donc c'est un mensonge de dire
qu'il ya besoin de l'équilibré puis
ensuite la réforme de monsieur macron
elle coûte très cher il faut savoir que
c'est entre 50 et 80 milliards d'euros
pour passer d'un système à l'autre donc
ça vient balayer évidemment tous les
arguments on va faire des économies il
ya deux choses qui peuvent aujourd'hui
assurer des retraites décentes à tous
les français c'est booster la natalité
ça le gouvernement n'en parle pas du
tout et c'est surtout faire de l'emploi
créé de l'emploi avec du protectionnisme
et du patriotisme économique c'est ça
aujourd'hui qui nous manque dans ce
système là et qui est éludée par le
gouvernement jean paul delevoye avait
fait une vague allusion lors d'une
interview chez nos confrères du journal
du dimanche en évoquant l'immigration
justement comme recours puisque on avait
un problème démographique nous parler de
la natalité
ça vous fait bondir au rassemblement
national avoir recours à cette justement
immigration pour que ce système temps
d'être plus viables
bon ça fait bondir une majorité de
français il faut bien le dire qui ne
supporte plus l'immigration qui constate
qu'aujourd'hui avec le nombre de
chômeurs que nous avons 6 millions de
chômeurs dans notre pays le nombre de
pauvres 9 millions jr ce sont d'abord
ces chômeurs là qu'il faut remettre au
travail sont ces pauvres là qu'il faut
aider c'est pas évidemment en faire
venir d'autres parce que ce que ne
disent pas les fanatiques de
l'immigration c'est que l'immense
majorité des gens que nous faisons venir
l'immense majorité des 132 mille
demandeurs d'asile l'immense majorité
des 276000 titre de séjour qui ont été
accordés en 2019
ils vont faire quoi mais ils vont
grossir les rangs des chômeurs ils vont
grossir les rangs des pauvres
donc ça va pas apporter une plus value
et surtout ça ne va rien faire pour
équilibrer notre système de retraite
on a parlé de ce climat de tension sa
sinistre sur le terrain lors des
manifestations des violences chacun se
renvoie la balle des violences
policières notamment emmanuel macron
christophe castel
qui ont fait pas une forme de mea culpa
mais cris ont en tout cas appelé à
peut-être plus de déontologie c'était la
bonne attitude ils ont pris conscience
peut-être du problème qu'il y avait
selon vous non je ne le pense pas ils
sont responsables de ce chaos
ils sont responsables à la fois des
mutilations parmi les gilet jaune et
sont responsables aussi des agressions
de policiers et des suicides dans la
police
ils ont alimenté les tensions ils ont
jeté donc les français les uns contre
les autres ils continuent de le faire
avec des déclarations d'ailleurs
totalement scandaleuse je me rappelle du
préfet l'allemand qui avait dit voilà je
ne suis pas votre de votre camp à une
manifestante donc tout ça évidemment
alimenté bien sûr bien sûr il est
totalement incompétent et je dirais il
est même dangereux
il est dangereux voilà le miz de
l'intérieur et peut-être seulement
incompétents en tout cas le préfet me
semble dangereux dans les propos qui
tient qui divisent les français pour
revenir sur le sujet moi je réfute la
formulation de violences policières ya
une violence aujourd'hui qui est
politique dont l'instrument peut-être la
police effectivement et qui s'est
dirigée contre des gilets jaunes qui
s'est dirigée contre des manifestants
mais en tout état de cause les hommes et
les femmes aujourd'hui qui portent
l'uniforme de la république doivent être
respectés ils effectuent un travail
admirable dans des conditions
éprouvantes avec des moyens insuffisants
donc il n'ya pas de violences policières
il ya une violence politique est
l'actualité c'est aussi emmanuel macron
forum de la shoah à jérusalem qui s'est
illustré ce soir ce serait créée en 1996
avec un certain jacques chirac
une altercation avec un policier
israélien le tout en anglais vous êtes
peut-être vu ce passage veut une
réaction
bon c'est de la comédie mais c'est vrai
que c'est un bien piètre acteur il veut
nous faire une chirac mais un petit peu
pauvre le seul souci c'est qu'on le voit
dans cette séquence il ya aucune
spontanéité tout et surjouée il ya
aucune sincérité d'ailleurs mêmes macron
qui parle très bien anglais d'habitude
on le voit il peut faire un discours
sans le moindre accent là il force son
accent français
donc pour rappeler évidemment
l'épisode de 96 de jacques chirac et moi
ce que je déplore et ce qui est quand
même dangereux c'est qu'en faisant ça
donc tout ça est calculé il fait un clin
d'oeil aux communautaristes en france
qui sont évidemment antisémites qui sont
hostiles à l'état d'israël
je trouve ça dangereux puisque lui dans
son nom et en même temps il fait cette
séquence
et puis condamne évidemment
l'antisionisme donc dans un discours
tout cela évidemment n'a aucun sens le
fait que le président français soit le
seul délit gens qui seront sur place à
se rendre dans les territoires
palestiniens à ramallah pour rencontrer
mahmoud abbas normalement il devait le
faire peut-être ce soir en tout cas elle
le fera cette semaine c'est une bonne
chose que le président français parle à
tout le monde c'est une bonne chose
moi j'aimerais qu'il soit clair en tout
cas il faut que nous soyons les alliés
et les protecteurs d'israël israël
il faut le dire est menacée de mort
toujours et
des grandes des états des terroristes
aujourd'hui constitue une menace pour
son indépendance pour la liberté des
israéliens je pense qu'il faut être sans
ambiguïté dans ce combat là puisque le
combat que mène israël c'est aussi notre
combat et je rejoins aussi les la lutte
contre l'antisémitisme en france voilà
qui doit être l'un des combats
fondamentaux mais la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme
il faut lui donner un nom c'est surtout
la lutte contre l'islamisme ce que
refuse de faire ce président de la
république un mot on arrive à la fin de
cette interview sur les municipales
puisque vous êtes candidat à sens un
petit mot tout d'abord sur cette
circulaire castaner je rappelle aux
téléspectateurs en dessous de 9000
habitants ne sera pas forcément obligé
d'étiqueter ça veut dire que les
décomptes on ne sera pas s'ils sont la
république en marche ou un autre parti
il ya beaucoup de parties notamment les
républicains qui dénoncent ceux là ce
que vous en faites partie au
rassemblement national oui bien sûr on
dénonce la manipulation la magouille de
ce gouvernement de cette circulaire qui
vise évidemment à a réhaussé
mécaniquement mathématiquement les
scores de la république en marche dont
la sociologie électorale évidemment se
situent principalement dans les grandes
villes dans les métropoles dans les
agglomérations
c'est pour si on prends mon département
de l'yonne par exemple vous avez
seulement trois communes qui vont être
comptabilisés là qu'ils sont au dessus
de 9000 habitants
donc c'est à dire que toutes les autres
et notamment des petites communes
d'ailleurs on en aura pas forcément de
deux candidats mais avec des maires qui
aimeraient aussi être représentés
politiquement donc donc seront passés
sous silence
moi je considère que c'est un déni de
démocratie que ces chiffres bien sûr et
ça montre bien que la république en
marche a très peur du résultat des
élections municipales
ils ont déjà beaucoup de mal à faire
leur liste beaucoup de mal à trouver des
candidats il s'objecte débauché à gauche
comme à droite ils sont obligés même de
cacher leurs étiquettes quelquefois pour
pour se présenter 2
les électeurs donc s'y montre bien que
ils sont je dirais apeuré giguère au
double tout de même je coupe mon arrivée
à la fin vous aussi au rassemblement
national vous savez pas toujours réussi
à faire le plein vous avez eu parfois du
mal à trouver des candidats et vous avez
ouvert d'ailleurs les sélections il n'y
a pas que la haine de soi on ouvre parce
que nous sommes dans une dynamique de
rassemblement mais nous assumons
pleinement nos couleurs nos valeurs et
nous aurons toujours le logo rassemble
nationale nous trompons pas nos
électeurs contrairement à nos acheteurs
et vous les avez trouvés tous vos
candidats alors à bas en tout cas moi
j'ai ma liste à sens donc une liste de
rassemblement puisque à peine un tiers
des membres de la liste ont éthique
terrassement nationale s'est uni de
rationnement communal donc qui cherche
évidemment à a changé de sens puisque
c'est mon slogan et vous espérez quel
score à sens la victoire
la victoire s'est terminé le temps où
leur assemblée nationale où le front
national faisait de la figuration
là nous sommes là pour gouverner nous
sommes là pour montrer ce que nous
savons faire et d'ailleurs quand on
regarde le bilan de nos mères et rennes
donc un peu partout à hénin beaumont à
fréjus à beaucaire il est excellent donc
nous pouvons le faire partout y compris
à sens merci beaucoup julien audy
d'avoir été avec nous en direct assure
rt france stopper les violences des
forces de l'ordre contre les
journalistes et le but de ce code de la
liberté de la presse pour la police un
code établi par le centre européen pour
la liberté de la presse et des médias et
qui arrivent en france plusieurs
syndicats et associations de
journalistes ont présenté aujourd'hui à
paris mathilde euros magnan et andrea le
bourgeois avec cynthia lauvergeon pour
les explications gilet jaune grève
contre la réforme des retraites des
conflits sociaux que les journalistes
doivent couvrir sur le terrain depuis un
an et demi les incidents avec les forces
de l'ordre sont de plus en plus nombreux
lors des manifestations pour y remédier
les syndicats snj et snj cgt veulent
adopter le code de la liberté de la
presse en huit points il essaie de poser
les bases de bonnes relations entre
journalistes et forces de l'ordre
en gros c'est permettre aux journalistes
de bien faire leur travail c'est à dire
donc
que quand ils sont signalés les journaux
les policiers constatent qu'ils sont
bien journalistes et donc contre les
embête pas évidemment l'interdiction
pour la police de saisir notre matériel
parce que beaucoup de reporter du
journaliste reporter d'image ont vu leur
matériel saisi par la police expliqué à
la police qu'un journaliste ou
simplement qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
journaliste avec une carte de presse et
caetera voyez des des choses toutes
simples dont on a l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui même ceux là ce n'est
plus possible en france un texte rédigé
par le centre européen pour la liberté
de la presse et des médias
sa porte-parole juge la situation dans
l'hexagone préoccupante
il y a des incidences calment grave où
les journalistes ont été interpellés
avec prononce ont été blessées à paris à
présent sans appel les forces de l'ordre
continuent il n'y a pas de banquette
publicité partout dans les médias et de
l'appât de la police c'est cette jeune
homme
les syndicats déplorent l'absence de
dialogue avec la police le snj cgt
affirme avoir envoyé un courrier au
ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner pour engager une discussion sur
le sujet mais sans réponse ce code est
rédigé en collaboration avec eurocop la
confédération européenne de la police je
trouve que c'est un bon début pour
ouvrir un dialogue sur
l'agression de sur les journalistes et
aussi pour montrer que c'est une
histoire de deux côtés pas seulement le
côté des journalistes mais aussi le côté
des policiers
reporters sans frontières a recensé 120
incidents dont 88 majeur ainsi que 54
journalistes blessés
en six mois de mobilisation des gilet
jaune en novembre dernier 13
journalistes ont porté plainte contre x
en compagnie de rsf pour dénoncer les
violences policières dont ils font
l'objet
et pour en parler nous sommes avec un
tableau et qu'elle secrétaire à la vie
syndicale du bureau national du snj cgt
bonsoir humblot et qu'elle merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france donc
avait une table ronde organisée cet
après midi autour de ce code comment ça
s'est passé qu'est ce qui est ressorti
bonjour merci pour l'invitation ça s'est
bien passé ce qui est sorti c'est qu'il
ya un constat partagé sur une situation
un problématiques en france une
compréhension de de ce que c'est le
journalisme comment le journalisme peut
s'exercer et que nous devons avancer et
travailler ensemble parce qu il y a
plusieurs groupes ou organismes
organisations qui font chacune des
comptages de leur côté et c'est très
bien que quand on travaille ensemble
pour répondre aux
au gouvernement ou pour alerter le
gouvernement que la situation ne devrait
plus continuer alors vous parlez
d'incompréhension quelle est elle
précisément cette incompréhension je
pense qu'il y en a plusieurs mais une
une des première c'est que le
gouvernement enfin
1 le ministre
christophe castaner a répondu à pierre
laurent en décembre dernier sur la
question de quel sont les journalistes
qui peuvent couvrir les manifestations
comme ans reconnaît les journalistes
professionnels de ceux qui s'habillent
un journaliste qui ne le sont pas et
voilà notre intention au cmj cgt en
invitant un lycée pmf et et
et la fédération européenne des
journalistes c'était de dire et redire
que le journalisme est un métier de
libre exercice et que donc tout le monde
pouvait travailler toute personne se
revendiquant journalistes pouvaient
travailler en manifestation et donc
voilà il fallait qu'on travaille
ensemble pour peut-être me notifier et
c'est bien mais qu'il ne pouvait pas y
avoir une considération par rapport à au
statut professionnel qui est quelque
chose qui relève plus du code du travail
au fait que quelqu'un ait ou pas une
carte de presse et ça la représentante
du du snj national dominique pradalié
par exemple a insisté pour dire ce n'est
pas au gouvernement à la police de dire
qui est légitime non pas pour courir une
manifestation clairement quels sont les
socios les solutions concrètes ils sont
ressortis cette table-ronde aujourd'hui
et surtout proposé par ce code des
solutions concrètes
aujourd'hui c'est difficile tant qu'il
n'y a pas de dialogue de vrais dialogues
où les gens s'écoute s'entendre
aujourd'hui en france ce dialogue et
n'existe pas on n'a pas de réponses ou
des réponses un peu à côté de la plaque
de la part du du gouvernement et avec
les syndicats de police évidemment il
n'y a aujourd'hui pas de dialogue ce qui
est intéressant c'est s'il ya une
solution
le le représentant de la police
belge qui qui est aussi délégué de rekop
le disait s'il n'y a pas de dialogue
c'est difficile de trouver des solutions
et et dans d'autres pays un petit peu en
allemagne mais déjà aux pays bas un peu
plus il montre que les échanges la
formation croisée que les journalistes
soient formés au travail de la police
que les policiers soient formés au
travail des journalistes
ce sont des solutions intéressantes mais
je pense que nous on est très loin et
qu'un premier pas serait de le renvoyer
ce code de la liberté de la presse pour
la police aux préfets dans les
départements au ministère aux syndicats
de policiers pour qu'on commence à se
parler parce que constat est difficile
alors parmi les participants il ya le
journaliste controversé un tas boivent
c'est celui d'ailleurs qui a tweeté que
macron étaient présents au théâtre ce
week-end avec voilà ce qui a suivi est
ce que c'est une bonne façon pour vous
d'établir le dialogue avec le
gouvernement d'avoir ce genre de membres
finalement parmi vous est ce que c'est
pas contre-productif
non pour moi 1re contraire c'est
justement un soutien de la profession
voire d'une partie de la forêt
profession mais d'une grande partie de
la profession qui est représenté par par
les syndicats donc aussi bien le snj le
snj cgt soutiennent que pour nous un tas
aboaf n'est pas un journaliste
controversé nous pas un journaliste
militant n'est pas un journaliste avec
un adjectif
il est journaliste et en france
aujourd'hui il a parfaitement le droit
d'exercer comme un journaliste pour un
média pourquoi quelqu'un qui
travaillerait chez vous crtc
régionaliser les questions et nous
spécialement attaqué pour la est
quelqu'un qui travaille
à l'opinion ou quelqu'un qui travaille
aux échos voilà les explications qu'il a
données moi je trouve très intéressante
parce que ça va au délà de juste de
l'application de la loi
il a été très sincère dans il a expliqué
son parcours et je trouve ça très
intéressant aujourd'hui on a en france
un des journalistes professionnels qui
sont quand même qu'ils se ressemblent
énormément et et voilà les gens des
banlieues ne sont pas énormément enfin
représentée parmi les journalistes ils
arrivent sont nécessairement d'études
mais avec qui s'exprime je trouve très
bien avec un sens de l'info il l'a
montré en juin dernier qui est très
intéressant autodidacte je suis désolé
mais ça fait peu ainsi avec le cas du
journaliste autodidacte donc pour nous
la profession a intérêt à le soutenir
quelle que soient ses idées comme on l'a
dit un dans le code
les journalistes ne doivent pas être
traité en criminel discriminer une
limite sur liste noire pour leur
attitude politique présumée merci
beaucoup
ragot et qu'elle d'avoir été avec nous
en direct france rester avec nous dans
quelques instants nous partirons aux
etats-unis au deuxième jour du procès en
destitution de donald trump sous feu des
projecteurs en débite son absence et
puis nous reviendrons sur la visite des
manuels maquereau en israël
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donald trump est à l'affût de 5
milliards enfin en tout cas preuve pour
une première tranche de travaux dont la
barrière n'est pas totalement construite
la totalité de la frontière c'est plus
de 3000 km le président des états unis
reprend le discours qu'il avait comme
candidat le présentant les migrants
comme des vecteurs de délinquance de
criminalité de trafic de drogue
il est certain que la majorité des
migrants et mexicains ou centres
américains qui sont aux états unis ne
sont pas là pour faire du trafic de
drogue mais pour travailler je ne sais
pas quoi dire les gens vivent ici elle
travaille ici au milieu des ordures
et j'ai dit à mes amis qui travaillent
ici qui peut être prudent un jour ça va
devenir un cimetière ici on fait des
charges où vous travaillez ces milliers
et ses dizaines de milliers de gens car
père en fils de fer où iront ils
c'est la seule chose quinzaine
la dri chargé comme une bête parce que
elle nous engloutit morceau par morceau
et nous y sommes déjà habitués
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
et
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
21h heure française merci de nous
rejoindre pour cette deuxième heure
d'émission tout de suite voici les
titres de l'actualité repris ce soir à
washington du procès en destitution de
donald trump place au débat de fond le
président américain en déplacement au
forum économique de davos en suisse est
absent même si je cite il adorerait y
être il est accusé par le camp démocrate
d'abus de pouvoir et d'entraver la bonne
marche du congrès emmanuel macron défend
son combat de chaque jour contre
l'antisémitisme lors de sa visite en
israël
dans le même temps une étude dévoilée
par le parisien lundi sion antisémitisme
fait un constat alarmant alors que les
actes à caractère antisémite sont en
hausse
comment expliquer cette recrudescence et
ce sentiment comment lutter ce sera
l'objectif de notre face à face à 21h30
le procès en vue d'une destitution de
donald trump a donc repris ce soir et
hier sans surprise le sénat à majorité
républicaine a rejeté toutes les
propositions des démocrates
le président américain est accusé
d'avoir exercé des pressions sur son
homologue ukrainien volodimir et nice
qui pour contrer son rival pour la
présidentielle joe biden on retrouve à
washington notre envoyé spécial de radel
razika bonsoir doha on peut dire que le
procès débute véritablement aujourd'hui
et bien ça y est on est entré dans le
vif du sujet après une journée
éprouvante hier l'accusation est en ce
moment en train de détail et de
présenter les faits qui sont reprochés à
donald trump alors c'est le démocrate
adam schiff le procureur en chef de ce
procès en destitution du président
américain qui a pris la parole en
premier donald trump est accusé de
d'abus de pouvoir et dont train va la
bonne conduite du congrès dans la sphère
ukrainienne et dès l'ouverture des
débats
adam schiff a accusé le président
américain de tricher le président trump
a bloqué des centaines de millions de
dollars d'aidé militaire à un partenaire
stratégique en guerre contre la russie
pour obtenir une aide étrangère lors de
sa réélection gazole d'action
en d'autres termes pour tricher rennais
souhaite de cette façon le président a
utilisé les pouvoirs officiels de l'état
dont il disposait et qui n'était qu'un
opposant politique pour se donner un
avantage lors d'un scrutin démocratique
stratagème a été entrepris pour la
raison simple mais perverse de l'aider à
se faire réélire en 2020
mais ce stratagème pour effet de
fragiliser nos élections libres et
équitables et de mettre en danger notre
sécurité nationale alors adam schiff et
toujours au moment où je vous parle
à la tribune il est en train de détail
est en fait tous les éléments recueillis
pendant l' enquête qui l'a supervisé
pendant plus de trois mois puis son
équipe qui composait de six élus
démocrates ils font également
le rôle de procureurs vont se succéder à
la tribune pour convaincre les sénateurs
de la culpabilité de donald trump dans
cette affaire l'ukrainienne il faut
savoir qu'ils ont 24 heures de temps de
parole à répartir sur trois jours puis
ce sera au tour de la défense ne
s'organise et ils ont également le même
temps de parole à savoir 24 heures sur
trois jours pour et bien tout simplement
présenter leurs arguments et défendre
donald trump alors pour les démocrates
c'est vrai que ce procès est perdue
d'avancé
on le sait le sénat est majoritairement
républicain mais l'objectif ici est
surtout de convaincre l'opinion publique
américaine qui serait dangereux de
réélire un tel président vous le savez
les élections vont bientôt avoir lieu
dans dix mois précisément
alors certes hier soir ils ont échoué
devant le sénat pour obtenir
justement la convocation de témoins clés
à venir témoigner lors de ce procès en
destitution
mais ils vont sûrement revenir à la
charge dans les prochains jours merci
doha en direct de washington et de son
côté le leader du parti démocrate
chaque chômeur de nom c'est un jour noir
pour le pays écouter quand a été donné
la corde pour le procès en destitution
du président trump
la première chose que le peuple
américain à vue a été les sénateurs
républicains votant contre un procès
équitable avec des preuves pertinentes
il est clair que le peuple américain est
en faveur d'un procès équitable et qu'il
a pu massivement les témoins et les
documents
c'était un genre sont une nuit sombre
pour le sénat il y avait en conséquence
un nuage qui flottent au dessus du
procès en destitution de donald trump
chômage iniquité je tiens à souligner
que le fait que mc cauley n'est modifié
sa résolution montre que les
républicains peuvent rendre ce procès
plus équitable s'il le souhaite
ce n'est pas une question de capacité
ils peuvent le faire s'ils le veulent
c'est une question de conscience
les républicains du sénat ont le pouvoir
dans leurs mains de faire un procès
équitable
ont-ils le faire quand c'est important
nous cherchons la vérité
le peuple américain veut la vérité nous
serions abandonné dans nos
responsabilités si nous le demandions
pas ces votes
rappelez vous c'est la seule fois où
nous sommes assurés d'obtenir un vote
sur les témoins et les documents et donc
nous ne serions pas faire notre travail
si nous n'essayons pas de rang ce procès
équitable nous allons continuer à le
faire et ceux qui le déterminera à mon
avis ce sera justement comment les gens
votent la conscience du peuple américain
que nous avons raison pour en parler
nous sommes en direct depuis shannan au
garat aux états unis avec anthony brian
logan blogueur politique c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soit
[Musique]
bonsoir anthony browne logan merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
les démocrates on l'entend il parle d'un
trop ce procès truqué d'une parodie de
pin résolution déposée par le chef de la
majorité républicaine
est ce que vous partagez cette opinion
sur toute cette affaire est truqué c'est
une affaire politique et démocratie
n'ont jamais levé juste après migration
souhaitait se débarrasser de lui il
voulait déjà le destituer d'autres
personnes au sein de son parti au sein
du parti démocrate ne le souhaitent pas
voir en tant que président il est
certain que pour eux les rocades
l'élection présentielle n'était pas
favorable à l'or pour l'instant avant
d'entrer dans le vif du sujet d'aborder
les chefs d'accusation qui visent donald
trump démocrates et républicains
débattent des règles du jeu c'est en
fait très technique
quel est l'enjeu de tout cela la
partance pour de la procédure de
restitution
la décision devrait être réservé à des
affaires très grave des deux crânes des
délits graves
mais ce n'est pas une case ici donc si
la destitution continue alors la con
c'est dur sera utilisé à chaque fois
qu'il ya un désaccord politique qui
pourrait être utilisé la prochaine fois
ci un démocrate élu comme président et
les républicains pour essayer pour se
débarrasser de ville via la destitution
procédure est vraiment détourné c'est un
embrassement est ce que finalement ce
procès en destitution n'est pas un coup
d'épée dans l'eau alors peut-être que
c'est un feuilleton qui intéresse les
américains mais d'une certaine manière
les démocrates sont évidemment contre
donald trump et les républicains pour le
président des états unis donc qu'est-ce
que ça va vraiment apporter selon vous
est-ce que ça peut changer quelque chose
les gones ne changea rien n'a vraiment
changé je pense que les démocrates
personnes qui puissent devenir président
en 2020 hillary clinton en 2016 était
plus forte
à l'époque que tous les candidats
démocrates aujourd'hui et pourtant elle
a perdu ses thèses ne perdent jamais le
deuxième tour d'une présidence qui la
procédure de destitution est donc juste
un moyen d'essayer de se débarrasser du
président par kilomètre quoi qu'ils
fassent ils n'ont pas gagné donc ça ils
se rabattent sur des choses comme cela
néanmoins est ce qu'on peut s'attendre
est ce qu'il est possible en tout cas
qu'il y ait un coup de théâtre lors de
ces audiences qu'on apprenne peut-être
des choses qu'on ne savait pas qu'ils
puissent nuire au président à trump
je pense que nous avons déjà tout est
ouvert nous avons déjà toutes les
informations qui pourraient ressortir
lors que la gauche a gun nancy peña si
elle
on a dit que c'est lors de la ruche à
gates que le la procédure de destitution
a été lancée et après presque trois ans
il ya rien année sur le nouveau-né
sortie de cette affaire donc je ne pense
pas qu'il va y avoir deux nouveautés
parce qu'il ya moins de temps à des
moins de ressources
aujourd'hui l'attitude de donald trump
ne change pas c'est toujours la même
très sûr de lui il ya en suisse à davos
il parle de chasse aux sorcières
aujourd'hui il n'y ronis même en disant
qu'il adorerait être là quelle est votre
réaction sur cette attitude son attitude
c'est parce qu'il sait que rien ne lui
arrivera le procès va bientôt être fioul
il ne va pas durer encore longtemps
peut-être une semaine deux semaines au
plus il n'y a aucun risque de perdre son
poste
il faudrait que vingt sénateurs votent
en faveur d'un retrait du président cela
n'arrivera pas s'il était vraiment
coupable d'un crime
alors on pourrait se dire très bien
destituant l'occurrence n'est pas le cas
dont la procédure est et partiel depuis
le tout début donc son attitude est très
sûr car il est certain qu'il va rester à
son poste et que après la procédure de
destitution pourra s'en servir lors de
la campagne pour dire à ses partisans
que les démocrates ont essayé de se
débarrasser de lui de se lancer un
renversement qui m'ont parlé c'est
qu'ils font voter pour lui en donne le
ton d'autant plus que personne à gauche
ne peut leur verse le battre est ce
qu'un procès sans accusé
c'est vraiment un procès équitable john
abizaid que le procès va être et tout à
deux parce qu'il n'y a pas grand chose à
trouver certains témoins seront
peut-être a appelé à comparaître mais
cela ne fera pas de différence
56 c'est mon cas et c'est toujours un
exercice vides de sens car depuis le
début ce n'était pas un véritable procès
sommes donald trump l'a dit c'est tout
n'est cela ne devrait même pas avoir
cours et le court la procédure de
destitution détourner de cet objectif
aussi juste que possible car dès le
début n'aurait pas dû en avoir
aujourd'hui ça sera ma dernière question
qu'est ce qui différencie ce procès en
destitution de donald trump est ce que
bill clinton avait vécu à l'époque de la
sphère levinsky en termes de résonance
aux états unis des problèmes même si
elle n'est pas allée jusqu'à la
destitution
la situation actuelle est bien plus
partiale bien pu passer la différence
clé entre la destitution des tons à 30
ans elle sait que personne ne disait
après l'élection de bill clinton qu'ils
allaient essayer de les destituer le
jour de son inauguration
parce que donald trump a été élu les
gens ont rapidement commencé à dire
qu'ils voulaient le destituer alors
qu'elle ait encore aucune cause ne
parlait pas encore de la fer russes et
on ne parlait pas encore de toutes les
autres affaires dont la destruction a
toujours hanté de notre un peu mais pas
bill clinton
merci beaucoup anthony à brens logan
d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle que
vous êtes blogueur politique merci à
vous et donald trump qui déclare qu
apple droite aider la police à accéder à
ces téléphones déclarations du président
américain alors qu'apple aurait renoncé
à chiffrer des sauvegardes icloud de ses
clients il ya quelques mois le
gouvernement américain avait annoncé sa
volonté d'instaurer une loi qui
interdise aux constructeurs
technologique de recourir à des
algorithmes de chiffrement 20 possibles
à caser pour les forces de l'or
un rétropédalage de la marque à la pomme
pour tenter de garder de bonnes
relations avec les autorités américaines
notamment le fbi à l'analyse de pedro
gonesse neto responsable numérique de la
république souveraine
il faut comprendre que c'est important
de chiffrer le vrai puisque aujourd'hui
des données non chiffrée n'importe qui
qui aura un accès physique au match
inobservés heures pour être copier les
données les exploiter quand les données
sont chiffrées si on n'a pas la clé de
déchiffrement ça rend beaucoup plus
complexe l'exploitation des données donc
effectivement c'est vital même qu'une
entreprise qui a des données
personnelles de quelqu'un les chiffres
pour au moins ralentir si des hackers ou
même des agences gouvernementales mal
intentionnées ou un certain nombre de
gens veulent accéder aux données ne
puisse pas le faire
on sait que l'aigle afat travail avec
les services de renseignement américains
il avait même la technique canaries
c'est à dire qu'en gros il disait on
pour ni rien jusqu'au moment il le
disait pluie ce qui permettait de savoir
qu'ils avaient été compromis qui nous
français si on a accédé à des données
par exemple du président de la
république ou de quelqu'un ce serait les
lois américaines qui gérait giresse a et
donc on n'aura aucun moyen aucun recours
de nous protéger pour ça et les états
unis la destination rêvée de plusieurs
centaines de migrants venus d'amérique
centrale
ils ont été refoulés hier par le mexique
ils ont improvisé un camp de fortune à
la frontière avec le guatemala ont soit
risqué beach
sur les bords du fleuve sushi hâter le
réveil est difficile
la veille plusieurs centaines de
migrants ont tenté de traverser cette
frontière naturelle entre le guatemala
et le mexique avant de se heurter au gaz
lacrymogène des gardes nationaux
mexicain pour être honnête on ne
s'attendait pas à ce que le gouvernement
mexicain réagisse de cette façon parce
que nous sommes des êtres humains nous
ne sommes pas des animaux
nous avons des enfants avec nous mais
hier rien et tout cela n'avait
d'importance ces migrants
majoritairement hondurien et
guatémaltèques font partie d'une
caravane comptant plus de 3000 personnes
déterminé à rejoindre des états unis
plusieurs centaines d'entre eux avaient
déjà tenté en vain samedi d'entrer
illégalement au mexique le ministre
mexicain de l'intérieur avait alors
averti qu'aucun laissez-passer ne leur
serait remis une fermeté réitéré ce
mardi lui à la liait au groupe
hier un groupe de 1000 personnes a tenté
d'entrer dans le pays dans la force
c'est une tragédie a été évitée
karl peut toujours y avoir de nombreux
problèmes surtout quand il ya des femmes
et des enfants
il faut être prudent et aujourd'hui nous
espérons que la prudence et le bon sens
prévale g ceux qui dirigent ces
mouvements il y aura une action
essentielle raisonnables et prudentes
mais c'est vers nous parce que nous
devons respecter un cadre juridique
parti mardi dernier de la ville de san
pedro sula dans le nord du honduras
cette caravane est la première depuis la
signature début juin d'un accord
migratoire entre mexico et washington
donald trump avait menacé de taxes
douanières le mexique si son voisin du
sud ne parvenait pas à bloquer le
passage de migrants le président
mexicain andres manuel lopez obrador
avait alors décidé l'envoi de 21 mille
gardes nationaux aux frontières nord et
sud du pays
les places demain au 5ème forum mondial
sur l'antisémitisme à jérusalem de
nombreux dirigeants internationaux se
réunissent pour commémorer les 75 ans de
la libération du camp d'auschwitz
l'événement aura lieu au mémorial de yad
vashem où thomas bonnet s'est rendu avec
à stéphanie choix la presse israélienne
est unanime il s'agit du plus grand
événement diplomatique jamais organisé
ici d'ailleurs les organisateurs sont
très agréablement surpris agréablement
surpris par la forte présence de
délégations internationales elles sont
au nombre de 49 49 délégations
internationales réunis ici à jérusalem
pour ce 5e forum mondial de l'eau low
cost qui commémore cette année les 75
ans de la libération du camp d'auschwitz
c'était en janvier 1945 ce jeudi 23
janvier
plusieurs leaders internationaux vont
prendre la parole il s'agit des
représentants des vainqueurs de la
seconde guerre mondiale ainsi que de
l'allemagne le pays qui a perpétré la
shoah et cela nous mène à notre première
polémique l'absence du président
polonais ici le président polonais qui
avait souhaité prendre la parole cela
n'a donc pas été possible et c'est ce
qui explique son absence on rappelle que
la pologne était le pays dans lequel
était basé le camp d'auschwitz l'autre
polémique qui met ici c'est la faible
présence des survivants de l'holocauste
ils sont seulement une trentaine à avoir
été invités à cette commémoration
[Musique]
oubliez ces débats d'ordre
organisationnel quand on entre ici dans
le mémorial de yad vashem à jérusalem
un mémorial composés d'énormément de
documents de témoignages et d'objets
ayant appartenu aux juifs exterminés
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale les
dirigeants internationaux qui font le
déplacement vont évidemment pouvoir
observer ces documents exceptionnels
cela permettra de se remémorer l'horreur
de la shoah mais également de combattre
l'antisémitisme moderne
c'est d'ailleurs tout sauf un hasard si
le titre de ce 5e forum mondial de
l'holocauste et celui ci se remémorer le
low cost combattre l'antisémitisme
[Musique]
la réunion de tous ses dirigeants pour
cet événement international intervient
dans un contexte particulier à plus d'un
titre d'abord il existe un différend
entre moscou et varsovie en décembre
dernier vladimir poutine a accusé la
pologne d'avoir collaboré avec
l'allemagne nazie pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale plus généralement le
président russe reproche à un certain
nombre de pays de minorer si ce n'est
d'occulter le rôle de l'union soviétique
contre l'allemagne nazie
l'autre contexte à prendre en
considération c'est l'actualité
internationale
il ya d'abord le dossier iranien qui
menace la stabilité régionale et qui
préoccupe particulièrement le
gouvernement israélien l'autre point
c'est le processus de paix au proche
orient un processus toujours à l'arrêt
depuis maintenant de longs mois et puis
il ya la situation politique en israël
où des élections législatives auront
lieu au mois de mars les troisièmes
élections législatives en un an pour ce
pays qui peine à former un gouvernement
tous ces sujets devrait être abordée
lors des entretiens bilatéraux qui vont
avoir lieu en marge de ce 5e forum
mondial de l'holocauste et qui ne font
que renforcer l'importance de cet
événement est de son côté manuel mais
croit rencontrer ce matin à miami
netanyahu le premier ministre de l'état
hébreu le président a également
improvisé une balade dans les rues de
jérusalem balade au cours de laquelle il
une altercation verbale avec des
policiers israéliens pour qu'ils le
laissent entrer dans l'église sainte
anne la basilique est l'un des quatre
territoires français de jérusalem
un peu plus tôt dans la journée lors
d'une conférence de presse conjointe
avec son homologue israélien reuven
rivlin
il a exprimé sa vision de
l'antisémitisme nous avons aussi décidé
de discuter et de poser très franchement
la question de l'antisionisme
aujourd'hui profondément lié à la
question de l'antisémitisme et je vous
remercie d'ailleurs de la carte et des
propos que vous venez d'avoir j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire
l'antisionisme lorsqu'il est la négation
de l'existence d'israël comme état est
un antisémitisme
monsieur le président vous avez eu la
gentillesse de rappeler à l'instant ce
que la france avait entrepris pour
lutter avec détermination et force
contre toutes formes d'antisémitisme
dans l'espace public qu'ils soient réels
ou virtuels et nous continuerons avec la
même détermination et nous lutterons
comme je me suis déjà engagé contre
l'antisémitisme le racisme tout discours
de haine qui vient diviser notre société
et en y et les fondements mêmes alors
oui nous avons passé des lois prix des
premières décisions d'autres vont venir
en particulier qui nous permettront de
lutter encore plus efficacement contre
les discours de haine et entre autres
d'anti sémitisme sur internet au liban
nouvelle manifestation anti système en
ce début de soirée après trois mois de
crise le pays a depuis hier un nouveau
gouvernement
validée par le président michel aoun et
des légers par le premier ministre
hassan diable mais les libanais qui
pénètre convaincu en hausse à nouveau
manifesté dans les rues de beyrouth et
précision de cyrielle benavides bühler
[Applaudissements]
la contestation perdure dans plusieurs
villes du pays après l annonce du
nouveau gouvernement libanais ce mardi
les manifestants dénoncent les ministres
fraîchement désigné comme appartenant au
même parti que ceux du gouvernement
précédent le nouveau premier ministre
hassan diab universitaire et ancien
ministre de l'éducation a dû tenir sa
première réunion ce mercredi matin
avertissant que son pays au bord de la
faillite faisait face à une catastrophe
selon une déclaration lue par un haut
fonctionnaire
nous sommes face à une impasse
financière économique et sociale
en réalité nous sommes face à une
catastrophe et nous devons alléger
l'impact et les répercussions de cette
catastrophe sur les libanais la
description du problème peut nous
prendre beaucoup de temps maintenant
mais les intitulés des problèmes sont
claires et je suis sûr que chacun
d'entre vous comprend l'ampleur des
risques des groupes de manifestants ont
barré les rues avec des pneus en feu
dans plusieurs quartiers de beyrouth
détente brûler des manifestants
repoussés par les forces de l'ordre avec
des canons à eau et des gaz lacrymogènes
des scènes de guérilla urbaine preuve de
la détermination de la rue en tant que
manifestants si le gouvernement donne le
coup d'envoi nous resteront
définitivement dans la rue et il y aura
certainement une escalade car nous ne
pouvons pas nous laisser faire face à
cette situation la famille frappe aux
portes de toulouse la pauvreté et la
crise financière l'asphyxient traverse
tous pays nous nous mobiliserons de plus
en plus dans que le gouvernement ne nous
écoutera pas le liban connaît une des
pires crises socio économique et
financière depuis la fin de la guerre
civile en 1990 depuis le 17 octobre
dernier
l'ensemble de la classe dirigeante est
accusé de corruption et d'incompétence
des attaques qui avaient poussé l'ex
premier ministre saad hariri a
démissionné donc dans quelques instants
notre débat sur l'antisémitisme
justement en france alors qu'une étude
dévoilée lundi par lots offerts du
parisien montre qu'un tiers des français
de confession de culture juive déclarent
se sentir régulièrement menacée en
raison de leur appartenance religieuse
nous en débattrons avec nos invités
d
[Musique]
cette édition du dakar en arabie
saoudite fait parler je pense que le
dakar va faire du bien pour ce qui est
de la découverte du terrain par lui-même
des paysages mais maintenant pour le
reste et bien justement il faut débattre
le pays n'arrête un bon produit
invendable
j'insiste sur la bande am parce que
justement c'est là que si vous voulez ce
qu'essaye de faire actuellement mohamed
ben salman le prince héritier c'est
d'essayer de modifier à la marge le
l'image de ce pays et vous comprenez
bien que la tâche est ardue trois
entraînements le pari est gagné mais au
niveau politique c'est pas ça voilà 7
entre amis on leur propose d'arabie
saoudite
peut-être que beaucoup de sportifs
ignore et puis bêtement on y va le fait
qu'une manifestation sportive se déroule
dans un pays qui effectivement comme
tous les deux les domaines dès qu'on
touche aux pressions des droits de
l'homme et de la femme évidemment bon
effectivement c'est peut-être pas
complètement sain y aller il faut
approfondir et peut-être qu'on en tirera
des enseignements de cette première
édition
mais moi je serais très heureux que ce
soit une femme qui gagne le dakar et son
papa
[Musique]
alexandre je faisais direct vous êtes
vous déjà dopé il n'y a jamais de ma vie
bravo en fait je vous pensiez que la
sphère du dopage en russie était
terminée pour vous trompiez
les documents sont arrivés et que j'ai
ouvert le dossier et j'ai eu
l'impression d'être recouverts de boue
la participation des athlètes russes aux
compétitions internationales est en jeu
cela concerne notamment des événements
tels que les jeux olympiques de tokyo et
la coupe du monde de football au qatar
c'est ma médaille je sais que je les
gagne honnêtement je ne rendrai jamais
comme il ya quatre ans le laboratoire
antidopage de moscou est au centre de ce
scandale
or qui a modifié la base de données
d'échantillons des sportifs et quel
rapport cela a t-il avec grigoriy
rodtchenko off ils ont pu remplacer des
résultats négatifs par des résultats
positifs comme si l'athlète avait déjà
consommé des substances interdites pour
l'approcher par la suite et le faire
chanter pour de l'argent
on
il y a une problématique d'augmentation
extrêmement importante de la demande en
eau depuis la révolution verte qui a
conduit à cette autosuffisance
alimentaire de l'inde dans ces zones
climatiques aride il ya quasiment plus
d'eau en surface
on compte maintenant à peu près sur le
pays de l'ordre de 25 millions depuis
pomper ce qui est six fois plus que la
chine
cette image d'une femme qui porte un pot
à eau sur la tête et une image que l'on
voit partout
pour les femmes c'est une charge énorme
des petites filles peuvent pas aller à
l'école parce qu'elles doivent aider à
cette tâche par exemple donc ça accentue
des inégalités 85% de l'eau consommée
en inde les par l'agriculture c'est un
des premiers exportateurs de blé de riz
des peas qui consomment énormément d'eau
pour être produite à l'échelle mondiale
d'eau virtuelle c'est à dire l'eau qui
est contenu dans les produits qui sont
échangées l'inde est un des plus gros
exportateurs d'eau donc c'est un
paradoxe c'est un paradoxe lensois
en effet l'afghanistan n'est pas un lieu
tranquille ce n'est pas un bon pays
l'afghanistan est un endroit très
dangereux pour quelqu'un de célèbre
[Musique]
abbas est devenu célèbre
avant même de réussir ses amis sur
facebook
ses camarades de classe même des gens
dans la rue et des parents disaient
qu'il ressemblait à bruce lee chaque
fois que quelqu'un appelle bruce si je
suis aux anges
abbas ali se présente comme bruce lee il
imite les actes des infidèles l'islam
dénonce des actes contre la religion
commis par les musulmans
il doit simplement continuer à
s'entraîner peu importe sa religion
qu'ils soient musulmans ou non
voilà quelqu'un qui ressemble à roussely
qui peut réussir à garder sa mémoire
vivante
cela fera revenir la figure de bruce lee
dans le cinéma et le sport c'est génial
pour la promotion du sport
[Musique]
21h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france merci de nous rejoindre alors
que le nombre de faits à caractère
antisémite a fortement augmenté en 2018
selon le ministère de l'intérieur
emmanuel macron est en visite en israël
il rappelle défendre son combat de
chaque jour contre ce fléau comment
expliquer cette recrudescence comment
lutter surtout contre elle de quels
moyens disposent en nous c'est l'objet
de notre face à face ce soir
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes sur ce
plateau avec noémie alioua journalistes
y 24 news hauteur de la sphère sarah
halimi aux éditions du cerf 2018 ses
côtés charles roseman essayiste auteur
de violence dans la république un
l'urgence d'une réconciliation paris la
découverte 2015
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être là
d'avoir accepté de jouer le jeu du débat
alors tout d'abord avant de commencer à
discuter christophe castaner 1 qui a
annoncé en février dernier une forte
augmentation des actes antisémites +74 %
entre 2017 et 2018 les explications en
images
[Musique]
tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
où
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
où
m
les chiffres qui font froid dans le dos
charles roseman comment vous expliquer
cette recrudescence des actes
antisémites en france et le fait que peu
de juifs aujourd'hui se sentent en
sécurité sur le territoire français je
crois qu'on a une fausse idée de
l'antisémitisme voix à l'antisémitisme à
partir de ce qui s'est passé par la
deuxième guerre mondiale la shoah hitler
le nazisme et on ne voit pas que
l'antisémite c'est quelqu'un qui ne se
voit pas qui ne se perçoit pas comme
quelqu'un de mauvais mais quelqu'un qui
réagit à la malfaisance des juifs
ça a été le cas depuis depuis toujours
dans l'histoire et c'est le cas
aujourd'hui par rapport à l'état
d'israël qui est un peu le juif des
nations et où l'on ou l'antisémitisme
aujourd'hui ses mutés et c'est la
malfaisance de l'état d'israël qui qui
est à l'origine de l'antisémitisme
aujourd'hui qui est parti d'un
antisémitisme musulman à partir de la
naissance de l'état d'israël qui a eu du
mal à accepter cette existence d'un état
souverain juifs à l'intérieur d'un
territoire entièrement musulman et il
s'est ensuite transférés dans des
milieux des milieux je dirais de gauche
en europe à la fois chrétien qui voit le
dans le dans le le palestinian et le les
personnes du tiers monde en général
comme des pauvres face à un monde plus
riches
quel monde occidental est également
l'état d'israël et même la réussite de
l'état d'israël a augmenté même cet
antisémitisme par rapport à cette
question de de la dynamique entre
pauvres et riches et puis le côté
dirait ce qui restait du marxisme qui
est le lag la la dynamique entre
dominants et dominés et où on voit des
milieux qui sont d'extrême gauche
aujourd'hui d'extrême droite pour des
raisons diverses qui ont qui ont accepté
cette ce transfert de l'antisémitisme
qui au départ était surtout d'origine
islamiste pour ça qu'on parle de nouvel
antisémitisme mais ce que vous voulez le
l'anti mites et on a toujours existé la
seule différence c'est qu'aujourd'hui
prend une nouvelle forme
il prend la forme de l'antisionisme
aujourd'hui on va pas dire sale juif on
va dire sale sioniste qui voulait c'est
juste une façon vis-à-vis de la loi de
se protéger c'est un argument mais je
crois que l'antisémitisme finalement le
lan disponible n'est qu'une nouvelle
forme de l'antisémitisme mais cet
antisémitisme si vous voulez aurait pu
trouver un autre argument si je puis
dire
et quand on parle de nouvel
antisémitisme ce qu'on veut dire par là
c'est pas qu'il est nouveau puisqu'il a
été théorisée déjà depuis vingt ans
notamment par l'historien georges
bensoussan on dit nouvel anti mites in
parce que justement ce n'est plus
l'antisémitisme chrétien qui s'appuyait
sur l'argument du déficit c'est à dire
les juifs sont assassinés
jésus c'était un argument qui avait été
utilisé pendant des millénaires pour
justifier l'antisémitisme aujourd'hui
les principaux antisémites se servent
des de sourates du coran et se servent
de l'argument d'israël pour condamner
les juifs et c'est pas uniquement des
condamnations alors il ya des chiffres
bien sûr qu'ils sont on voit une
explosion des chiffres de
l'antisémitisme mais au-delà des
chiffres c'est des histoires c'est des
enfants qui se font massacrer en allant
à l'école c'est des gens qui se font
assassiner et c'est vrai que toutes ces
réalités l'a finalement c'est
l'antisémitisme d'aujourd'hui et c'est
la question de l'insécurité beaucoup
plus largement parce que la question
antisémite il ça me semble très
important lors de la question hante
limited ne pourra pas de toute façon mad
régler tout seul il faut un plan
beaucoup plus globale et c'est pour ça
que le destin des juifs est intimement
liée en tout cas en france au destin de
la nation
sharon il ya une pression que j'aimerais
apporter vous paraît tous les deux de
l'état d'israël mais est ce que ce n'est
pas plutôt parfois la politique tout
simplement du gouvernement il serait
allé en local
depuis un petit moment bien sûr bien sûr
écrit parce que la recrue distance et
quand même récente il ya eu ce que
certains dénoncent et appel faisait que
ce n'est pas votre cas mais en tout cas
une forme de colonisation
certains en tout cas des noms cela ce
que ce n'est pas méchant mais je me fais
l'avocat de l'intéressée intéressant
parce qu'ils sont avec les pas des
solutions sous les 11 secondes les gens
devant leur tv souhaite bien sûr mais je
sais ce que c'est pas ça le point de la
politique du gouvernement israélien est
constamment critiqué critiquable les
premiers sont les israéliens si vous
voulez il ya une démocratie extrêmement
forte en israël avec des partis
politiques qui s'oppose de façon très
dure avec un camp anti natanyahou
extrêmement puissant j'ai participé avec
24 nous à de nombreuses manifestations
d'anti natanyahou dandy bibi comme ils
s'appellent il ya une démocratie très
forte
la critique de natanyahou est
extrêmement puissante elle existe en
israël comme à l'extérieur elle est
possible et plus que ça j'ai envie de
vous dire n'importe qui encore euro a le
droit de critiquer natanyahou où la
politique de l'état hébreu où la
colonisation si vous voulez appeler
comme ça où tout autre chose qui est
rattachée à israël mais le problème si
vous voulez c'est que cet antisémite il
n'a rien à voir avec une à une
argumentation construite intelligente
sur laquelle on peut débattre sur la
politique de l'état d'israël ça n'a rien
à voir c'est un masque la preuve c'est
que c'est irrationnel
la plupart du temps les gens qui qui qui
prennent l'argument d'israël pour
critiquer les juifs ne ne sont ne sont
pas rationnels si vous voulez c'est là
toute la ville
l'antisionisme sous couvert de l'enzyme
d'un antisionisme et là il ya quelque
chose qu'il faut comprendre c'est qu'il
ya une différence entre critiquer une
politique et la diabolisation
il ya une diabolisation d'israël sur les
mêmes têtes qui a eu une diabolisation
des juifs
c'est à dire les juifs dans le moyen
haut moyen-âge tuer des enfants
innocents
les juifs de me voulait de la domination
du monde par l'argent et donc qui a la
même chose avec l'état d'israël c'est à
dire qu est ce qu une diabolisation une
diabolisation
c'est quand d'abord on exagère les
méfaits qu'ils peuvent être réelles
juif effectivement ont participé à des
mouvements bolchevique l'époque de
hitler c'était le grand thème de hitler
c'était les les exactions commises par
les bolcheviks dans entre les années
dix-huit années 30 la même façon il ya
un capitalisme il ya eu des banques
juive et c'est donc il ya des réalités
mais le problème la diabolisation
c'est que ces réalités d'une part sont
exagérées d'autre part font l'objet de
rumeurs et de mensonges et de propagande
et d'autre part elles sont je dirais on
ne regarde pas l'ensemble du contexte
c'est à dire arrêter des enfants par
exemple de 12 13 ans ça paraît quelque
chose d'ignoble mais on ne vois pas pour
quelle raison et on ne dit pas pour
quelle raison ces enfants ont été
arrêtés
par exemple on ne fait pas la différence
entre ce qui se passe en israël y
compris avec gaza et ce qui se passe en
syrie
le nombre de morts et de deux
palestiniens qui ont été tuées au liban
où étais tu es en jordanie qui ont été
tuées en syrie est largement plus
important que les palestiniens tués en
un an par les israéliens
on ne fait pas par exemple la différence
entre un conflit qui a fait 70 milles
mort en use cinquante mille morts je
sais pas exactement en 70 ans et des
conflits comme en syrie où on a quatre
cent mille morts entre le conflit entre
l'iran et l'irak 1 million au nord avec
des enfants tués
dans toutes ces situations là c'est ça
la diabolisation
il ya quelque chose de très important
aussi qui me paraît très important s'est
il faut absolument dissocier aussi
toutes ces questions là parce que là on
est en train de faire une sorte
d'amalgamé où justement on essentialise
le juif comme le sioniste comme
l'israélien et on met tout ça dans un
énorme sac en pensant que c'est la même
chose alors que en france par exemple si
on prend la question française il y a
toujours eu des juifs français sioniste
ou pas c'est leur opinion mais en quoi
les juifs français devrait payer entre
guillemets pour la politique de
netanyahu
qu'est ce qui fait que eux aujourd'hui
on
traite de sale sioniste alors que
parfois parfois ils n'ont jamais été en
israël parfois c'est pas l'heure
question c'est pas leur réalité si salée
et bien ils ont choisi mais encore une
fois ils n'ont pas à payer les pots
cassés et ce qu'on voit c'est qu'à
chaque fois qu'il se passe quelque chose
en israël les juifs français payent et
la preuve le premier argument c'est
évidemment dans l'histoire récente c'est
le seconde intifada c'est à dire que
lorsqu'il y a eu une histoire politique
très compliqué en israël c'est bien il
ya eu une explosion des actes
antisémites et on a envie de vous dire
mais qu'est ce qu'ils ont à voir là
dedans
les juifs qui vivent en france et qui se
retrouvent agressé en bas de chez eux
qu'est ce qu'ils ont à voir avec moi ça
avec la réponse politique et notamment
celle de d'emmanuel macro aujourd'hui
encore lors de cette conférence de
presse à jérusalem aux côtés de benyamin
netanyahou le président qui a affirmé
que la négation de l'état d'israël était
de l'antisémitisme écouter
l'antisionisme lorsqu'il est la négation
de l'existence d'israël comme état et
antisémitisme 75 ans après la libération
des survivants d'auschwitz des citoyens
de france et d'ailleurs sont pris pour
cible parce qu'ils sont juifs
ce retour de la haine entre nos temps
présent elle a donc emmanuel lacroix est
ce qui prend la réponse du bon goût du
bon côté selon vous mon avis à emmanuel
macron un grand talent pour essayer de
plaire à gauche à droite un peu partout
et et je pense qu'il a aussi son son
rapport à israël
alors je ne suis pas dans le secret des
dieux et je ne connais pas le les
alliances les les demandes qui lui sont
faites au point de vue de géostratégie
mais je parle simplement de sa de la
peur de ce gouvernement de ce qui
pourrait se passer dans les banlieues
s'il prenait des positions uniquement
pro israélienne parce que je pense que
que il a déjà la réputation comme
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui se dit donc dans
les banlieues françaises la réputation
d'être dans les mains des sionistes
comme on le dit justement très très
habituellement il a la réputation
d'avoir travaillé dans la banque
rothschild donc il ya tout un courant
assez le président français à se rendre
dans les territoires palestiniens lors
de gens qui sont celles où j'allais je
pense que nous avons un gouvernement qui
a très peur de ce qu'ils pouvaient
embrasé les banlieues et donc il faut
qu'ils ménagent la chèvre et le chou
mais cette loi va dans le mauvais sens
pour lui si je vous écoute parce que
associés il va faire le jeu mais je
pense que il en faisant ce qu'il a fait
aujourd'hui avec la police israélienne
en imitant chirac il a essayé de donner
d une caution à à une critique de des
israéliens aussi donc il essaye de ils
essayent de gouverner comme ça au au
mieux ou au pire en essayant justement
de de plaire à tout le monde
sur cet épisode
c'est un reste de la communication
politique à ces ratés puisque c'est
qu'une pâle copie de l'original il a
essayé de rejouer un petit peu l'épisode
chirac qui a marqué d'ailleurs son
quinquennat mais qui est aujourd'hui
c'est une redite si vous voulez qui est
assez qui assez risible d'abord parce
qu'il essaie d'asseoir une souveraineté
sur un territoire alors qu'on sait
qu'aujourd'hui en france il est
extrêmement contestée est allé gilet
jaune dans la rue demain tous les
samedis depuis des mois il ya les liait
les grévistes y aller il ya les
retraites ce volet il est une lui-même
extrêmement contestée sur son territoire
et il va en israël pour faire la leçon
de morale c'est d'un point de vue
politique assez pitoyable d'un point de
vue communicationnel assez ridicule je
pense qu'il ne gagnera rien en est
d'ailleurs il fait preuve d'un manque
d'originalité à c'est assez
catastrophique pour ce qui est de ses de
son discours sur la question de
l'antisémitisme moi je trouve qu'il a un
discours depuis son quinquennat depuis
le début de son quinquennat assez assez
ferme sur la question je veux dire il se
positionne il a bien conscience qu'il ya
un problème le on peut se souvenir par
exemple qu'il a cités et là il a été
quand même assez assez courageux de
citer le nom de sara lee me lors des
commémorations d'anniversaire du vel
d'hiv souviens c'était encore une
question très compliquée à ce moment là
il a fait le choix d'en parler c'est une
preuve de courage je pense qu'il veut
malgré tout montré aux juifs de france
que le pouvoir les soutient que le
pouvoir et de leur côté qu'ils se
soucient de leur sécurité et de leur
bien-être
en france malheureusement c'est comme et
encore une fois je c'est important de
voir toujours cette question là dans une
perspective beaucoup plus globale le
problème c'est que comme toujours les
paroles n'enchaîne pas des actes si vous
voulez c'est à dire qu' il ya des grands
discours
il y à des politiques on se souvient de
la fameuse phrase de manuel valls et
julie sans la france c'est pas la france
il y a des grands discours qui qui
montre la protection de l'état français
vis-à-vis de leurs concitoyens juifs
le problème c'est que dans les actes on
voit qu'il n'ya pas de répercussion
puisque les actes antisémites continue à
augmenter puisque malgré tout il ya un
sentiment qui se développent chez les
juifs de d'insécurité et donc c'est le
problème de la deux
de la parole politique si vous voulez
qu'il n'a plus de qui n'a plus vraiment
qui n'est plus efficace et ça c'est
beaucoup plus large
sincèrement c'est avec des lois comme ça
d'assimiler le sionisme antisionisme à
l'antisémitisme qu'on va régler la
question d'ailleurs je voulais vous
faire réagir avec michèle sibony
ancienne vice-présidente de l'union
juive française pour la paix pour elle
la loi maillard est une loin ou qui
démocratique et qui bafouent l'égalité
entre les citoyens français je vous
laisserai réagir après c'est une très
mauvaise décision de l'assemblée
nationale très antidémocratique très qui
vient en contre-pied du de l'article 1
de la constitution de la vème république
qui promeut l'égalité de tous les
citoyens entre eux c'est une résolution
dangereuse pour les juifs elle les met
en en
elle leur donne un statut très
particulier à l'essor du collectif
national au fond le racisme en france
existe il vise les juifs mais il vise
aussi les arabes ils visaient musulmans
et de ville et noir il vise les roms il
vise les asiatiques
il fallait prendre peut-être à
l'assemblée nationale la mesure du
racisme de ses ravages en france mais
mettre en exergue de cette manière là
l'antisémitisme pour des raisons à
l'évidence politique on y reviendra me
paraît ça fait de cette loi une des lois
qui seront qui resteront dans l'histoire
comme une loi scélérate une réaction
justement ça mais plutôt en danger les
juifs est ce que vous partagez cet avis
de michèle sibony
alors je pense qu'elle n'a pas lu déjà
le texte parce que ce n'est pas une loi
contraignante
ce n'est pas une loi qui aura une
incidence sur le code pénal sur le code
civil c'est quand même important de le
rappeler parce que on a l'impression que
les gens prennent ça comme un acte de
censure
on sait que le justement la censure se
développent et finalement en allant
contre cette loi on a l'impression
d'aller contre la censure qui ce qui est
totalement faux
parce que c'est une loi symbolique donc
c'est une loi qui n'implique pas de
modification du code pénal et du code
civil c'est quand même important de le
préciser où il mêle parle bien de
symboles ça
mais les juifs en danger parce que ça
les enlève ça les extraits du reste de
la population s'en balance
comment est ce que cette loi a été
décidée elle a été décidée après que le
philosophe alain finkielkraut a été
agressé par les gilet jaune
il a été agressé sur quelques chaises
insu sur certains généraux absolument
certain gilet jaune
il a été traité de sale sioniste de
merde je précise que deux salles cioni
de merde d'accord donc il a peut être
été de salses et traiter de sale juge
non comment est ce que la loi peut
répondre dans ces cas là c'est ça la
question
il ya un problème et un vide juridique
alors il n'a pas été comblé puisque
encore une fois ces lois non
contraignante mais il y a un problème à
partir du mans on peut se cacher
derrière
si vous voulez des démos qui sont des
mots valises on sait très bien ce qu'ils
veulent dire charles rojzman bah moi je
pense d'abord que il faut voir d'où les
gens parlent la madame simonet fait
partie d'un groupement très violemment
anti sioniste et elle parle au nom de
cette extrêmement solitaire cette
idéologie anti sioniste mais moi je
voulais dire autre chose quelque chose
d'à propos quelques autres choses à
propos de l'antisionisme antisémitisme
c'est le sait le fait que les gens
parlent
dames c'est le si vous voulez
l'antisionisme et l'antisémitisme est
surtout le fait des milieux non
populaire c'est-à-dire deux milieux qui
sont à moitié du quai qui lisent des
journaux qui lisent qui suivent des
réseaux sociaux et qui ne connaissent
pas véritablement l'histoire de ce
conflit
je m'en suis aperçu bien des fois qu'ils
ne connaissent pas le contexte dans
lequel ces choses-là se passe et qui
sont influencés par des idéologies comme
je le disais tout à l'heure des
idéologies antique néo anticolonialiste
des idéologies quelquefois clairement
antisémite de chrétiens par exemple je
crois que c'est quelqu'un parlait de des
vertus chrétiennes qui inquiète qui sont
devenues folles c'est à dire de milieux
que de chrétiens de gauche
oui c'est ça chesterton et de milieux
néo marxiste de milieux qui ont la
nostalgie d'un prolétariat qui n'existe
pas et qui l'ont transféré sur les
musulmans et donc on a quand même dans
dans dans toute cette histoire
on a beaucoup d biologie et le derby
complèment gérer davantage mais location
oui ce n'est pas d'éducation d'ailleurs
assez inquiétant un français sur des
points qui ne connaît pas l'histoire de
la shoah ça augmente chez les jeunes 20
% des jeunes qui connaissent pas
vraiment cette législation bien dans un
sondage de ifop publié en 2018 un
français sur 10 qui n'a jamais entendu
parler de la choix d'ailleurs
jean-michel blanquer a affirmé qu'il
s'attaquerait à ce sujet ce que c'est
pas là le vrai problème en rajouter je
ne pense pas que ce soit un problème
d'éducation je pense est un problème de
casser ces milieux tous ces milieux qui
qui
il veut uniquement avec une seule
propagande en ce qui concerne les
enquêtes
moi je ne crois pas personnellement que
ce sixième des français n'a pas entendu
parler de la shoah un sondage ifop-le
1018 je sais c'est pas moi et je crois
qu'il ya la volonté de dire qu'on ne
sait pas ce que c'est que la shoah
parce que derrière piquet apparemment de
l'enseigné dans certains quartiers c'est
ce que nous lui et le ministre de
l'éducation
absolument et c'est pour ça que moi qui
travaille dans plusieurs pays étrangers
à réconcilier des gens qui sont des
ennemis des adversaires qui ont dû faire
face à des guerres civiles
je crois qu'on devrait aider les gens à
sortir de leur milieu à se rencontrer
plutôt que les éduquer leur expliquer
comme autrefois hunted est d'éduquer les
gens à l'antiracisme avec sos racisme
c'est pas bien être à 6 on voit bien que
ça a servi à rien je pense qu'il faut
plutôt que les gens qu'on aide les gens
à sortir dans le milieu ils disent après
c'est un peu le travail que je fais moi
à être en conflit à se parler mais je
suis en situation ça serait bien de
terminer effectivement sur ce point
position stylisation son site et
spirituelle conflictuelle
c'est à dire allez allez tous se mettre
sur la table nous dans un processus où
les gens petit à petit ce faux en
confiance et se disent réellement ce
qu'il pense et partagent leurs
informations
et je dirais ensemble deviennent un peu
plus intelligent un peu plus raisonnable
un an et demi à lyon il ya plusieurs
choses mais il arrive que m'a beaucoup
marqué c'est le livre de l'historien
georges bensoussan qui s'appelle
l'instrumentalisation de la shoah et qui
explique très bien que finalement
parfois on fait trop façon on pense que
l'histoire va se répéter de la même
façon or l'histoire ne se répète jamais
de la même façon donc je ne crois pas
moi quand un enseignant la shoah tous
les jours aux enfants ils auront moins
antisémites au contraire
c'est justement parce que c'est une
nouvelle histoire qu'il faut la voir
avec des nouveaux yeux et ce ne sera pas
suffisant
bien sûr que c'est une très bonne mesure
et ce sera pas suffisant et on ne
luttera pas contre l'antisémitisme en
enseignant davantage la choix je ne
crois pas au contraire c'est plutôt
l'esprit critique qui a besoin d'être
renseigné mais pour revenir peut-être
sur ce que sur ce que vous disiez je
suis assez d'accord en fait vous êtes en
train de critiquer en gros le modèle
communautariste c'est à dire que le vrai
problème c'est justement quand on parle
de en france quand manuel valls part
parlé d' apartheid en tout cas de deux
quartiers ghettoïsés c'est ça le grand
danger et quand vous dites que les gens
que ce mélange plus c'est ça le grand
danger encore une fois ça c'est une loi
en question les mélanger charles
grossman puisque vous avez écrit un
livre sur le sujet les solutions
justement pour mélanger les permis a
priori il faut mettre ensemble des gens
qui ont dans des villes dans des dents
des dans différents endroits du pays qui
ont des problèmes à traiter des
problèmes douloureux pas forcément des
militants une cause ou d'une autre mais
des gens je crois que le modèle pour moi
ça a été le démarrage des gilets jaunes
c'est à dire la prise de parole de
citoyens avant que ce mouvement soit
récupéré comme on sait comme il l'a été
mais vraiment une une prise de parole de
gens qui savent des choses qui ont
besoin de les partager qui ont besoin
d'être écoutés et souvent c'est parce
que les gens je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec ce que dit noémie à loyat
je crois que les gens vivent dans un
milieu et non que la propagande de leur
milieu et ne sortent jamais de ce milieu
c'est ça la fout de la fin le problème
c'est que c'est un mot c'est une parole
qui est complètement cessé un mot qui
parfois ne peut plus rien dire mais si
on le prend à son sens le plus strict la
vraie solution c'est la république c'est
à dire c'est un modèle républicain avec
du bien commun avec des particularismes
qui restent à la maison tirage chez soi
et on essaie crée du commun au delà des
différences c'est la solution le
problème c'est que le mot république
aujourd'hui on a l'impression qu'on ne
veut plus rien dire mais avec
le propre de la démocratie qui est le
conflit parce que le conflit sans
violence c'est le propre de la vie
démocratique et il ya plus de conflits
comme il ya plus de conflit chacun reste
chez soi et se développent une image
fantasmée des autres moi je vois bien
que par exemple
même dans des murs parlent de
l'antisémitisme mais moi je sais qu'il
ya des milieux dans lequel on dit pis
que pendre des français on dit quand on
est quand on est soi même de nationalité
française ont dit mais les français qui
par exemple certains milieux musulmans
vont dire les français qui ne sont pas
musulmans sont vont aller en enfer
effectivement on va pas bien surtout les
formes de racisme ce soir ça va être en
tous cas c'est le mot de la fin merci à
vous noémie aoudia et charles de semaine
avoir été avec moi on dirait que tu
perds tu es français la fin de ce
journal on se retrouve donc quatre
minutes pour un nouveau point complet
sur l'actualité
[Musique]
que veut-il dire en japonais et qui
comme mourir dont il veut dire qu'il ne
sort pas de chez soi tout simplement le
propre du phénomène hikikomori c'est que
on trouve des jeunes au japon qui refuse
de sortir de chez eux alors qu'eux ils
n'ont pas de pathologie identifiée dans
la nomenclature psychiatriques
aujourd'hui les quais komori ne sont pas
des fadas de jeux vidéo c'est pas des
gens qui passent tout leur temps dans
leur chambre scotché à l'ordinateur à
jouer aux jeux vidéo et c'est un
documentaire qui permet de comprendre en
quoi ce phénomène est vraiment
spécifique de la culture japonaise au
japon la pression scolaire est
extrêmement forte
mais les parents s'endettent souvent à
vie pour que leurs enfants fassent des
études et puis vous savez au moment de
la crise d'adolescence un bel quelque
chose qui est remis en question
c'est une super méga crise d'adolescence
considérablement majorait par la
situation économique culturel social
familial qui lie au japon
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs sont joués mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de films
stratégies peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
je suis l'ex maire et chaque semaine
dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france a même là ne
suis pas un terroriste
iam non je ne suis pas un terroriste je
ne suis pas un terroriste
[Musique]
de nos jours peu importe où vous êtes
vous êtes surveillés très probablement
les drones militaires ont fait des
milliers de morts innocents et peuvent
attaquer à tout moment et n'importe où
comme ils veulent à plus de 10 mètres
d'altitude
vous ne vous rendrez même pas une que
vous êtes surveillés et en cas d'
attaque vous ne les voyez même pas
walt dire ce que nous avons vu dans le
scénario d'après le 11 septembre c'est
que dans le cas du pakistan la cia a
reçu l'autorisation en tuer ils
bombardent des villages il y à des
villages de madras des maisons parfois
il déclare avoir supprimé un terroriste
et plus tard on voit en vie alors qu'ils
ont ils tué il m'avait fait tuer des
enfants pour le pays sera fait pour le
profit a aucune comment pouvez-vous
sourire
[Musique]
j - avant le forum de la shoah à 40
dirigeants sont à jérusalem à mieux les
présidents russes allemands et français
à s'être entretenu avec le premier
ministre israélien emmanuel macron
rencontre le dirigeant palestinien
selon lui la négation de l'existence
d'israël comme état tient de l'ampli
sémitisme a repris ce soir à washington
du procès en destitution de donald trump
le sénat entame les débats de fond le
président américain en déplacement au
forum économique de davos en suisse
étapes seront même si je suit il l'adoré
y être il est accusé par le camp
démocrate d'abus de pouvoir et entrave à
la bonne marche du congrès le liban fait
face à une catastrophe avertit le
nouveau premier ministre qui promet de
répondre aux défis immenses qui
attendent
gouvernement loin de satisfaire les
libanais des paroles qui n'apaise pas la
colère de la rue
mais août est actuellement en proie à
des heures
[Musique]
merci nous rejoindre en direct sur arte
france 1ère place demain donc 5ème forum
mondial sur l'antisémitisme à jérusalem
de nombreux dirigeants internationaux se
réunissent pour commémorer les 75 ans de
la libération du camp d'auschwitz
l'événement aura lieu au mémorial de yad
vashem où thomas bonnet s'est rendu avec
stéphane et joie la presse israélienne
est unanime il s'agit du plus grand
événement diplomatique jamais organisé
ici d'ailleurs les organisateurs sont
très agréablement surpris agréablement
surpris par la forte présence de
délégations internationales elles sont
au nombre de 49 49 délégations
internationales réunis ici à jérusalem
pour ce 5e forum mondial de l'eau low
cost qui commémore cette année les 75
ans de la libération du camp d'auschwitz
c'était en janvier 1945 ce jeudi 23
janvier plusieurs leaders internationaux
vont prendre la parole il s'agit des
représentants des vainqueurs de la
seconde guerre mondiale un cycle de
l'allemagne le pays qui a perpétré la
shoah et cela nous mène à notre première
polémique l'absence du président
polonais ici le président polonais qui
avait souhaité prendre la parole cela
n'a donc pas été possible et c'est ce
qui explique son absence soit rappelle
que la pologne était le pays dans lequel
était basé le camp d'auschwitz l'autre
polémique qui met ici c'est la faible
présence des survivants de l'holocauste
ils sont seulement une trentaine à avoir
été invités à cette commémoration
[Musique]
oubliez ces débats d'ordre
organisationnel quand on entre ici dans
le mémorial de yad vashem à jérusalem
un mémorial composés d'énormément de
documents de témoignages et d'objets
ayant appartenu aux juifs exterminés
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale les
dirigeants internationaux qui font le
déplacement vaut évidemment pouvoir
observer ces documents exceptionnels
cela permettra de se remémorer l'horreur
de la shoah mais également de combattre
l'antisémitisme moderne
c'est d'ailleurs tout sauf un hasard si
le titre de ce 5e forum mondial de
l'holocauste et celui ci se remémorer le
low cost combattre l'antisémitisme
[Musique]
la réunion de tous ses dirigeants pour
cet événement international intervient
dans un contexte particulier à plus d'un
titre d'abord il existe un différend
entre moscou et varsovie en décembre
dernier vladimir poutine a accusé la
pologne d'avoir collaboré avec
l'allemagne nazie pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale plus généralement le
président russe reproche à un certain
nombre de pays de minorer si ce n'est
d'occulter le rôle de l'union soviétique
contre l'allemagne nazie
l'autre contexte à prendre en
considération c'est l'actualité
internationale
il ya d'abord le dossier iranien qui
menace la stabilité régionale et qui
préoccupe particulièrement le
gouvernement israélien l'autre point
c'est le processus de paix au proche
orient un processus toujours à l'arrêt
depuis maintenant de longs mois et puis
il ya la situation politique en israël
où des élections législatives auront
lieu au mois de mars les troisièmes
élections législatives en un an pour ce
pays qui peine à former un gouvernement
tous ces sujets devrait être abordée
lors des entretiens bilatéraux qui vont
avoir lieu en marge de ce 5e forum
mondial de l'holocauste et qui ne font
que renforcer l'importance de cet
événement mais alors que manuel macron
était attendu à la basilique sainte anne
à jérusalem les services de sécurité
français et israéliens se sont disputés
à l'entrée du monument une altercation
brutale à laquelle le chef de l'état a
pris part et maintenant la province a
exigé le départ de policiers israéliens
de l'église sainte-anne propriété de la
france depuis le xixème siècle une scène
qui rappelle un célèbre incident qui
avait impliqué jacques chirac en 1996
écouter justement l'explication on a
donné le président yvon à sainte anne
qui est un domaine français et l'injure
qui était assez classique il ya eu un
moment de d'énervement entre des équipes
de sécurité
il me revenait d'y mettre bon ordre en
ré expliquant quelles sont les règles
depuis que la france a ainsi quelques
domaines c'est vrai pour sainte-anne la
sécurité israélienne qui a fait un
travail formidable mais côté dans les
rues
tout a été très calme elle s'arrête aux
portes de sainte anne c'est la sécurité
française qui prend le relais et
pertinent pour sa jacques chirac je
n'aurais pas dit c'était prémédité un
pour voter non pas du tout parce que je
pensais que ça se passerait bien mais
c'est vous qui le faites maintenant
non non non c'était pas et pas de
préméditation parce que je pensais que
ça se court passerait bien c'est un peu
le jeu et la parenthèse a été a été
refermé non vieux potes non parce qu'on
n'a pas eue regarder le 17e après j'ai
salué les demandes de sécurité on s'est
serré la main a chaleureusement les
choses et où vivent là il ya parfois il
ya des moments où on cherche la bonne
limite si beaucoup de choses sont des
histoires de frontières vous savez
parfois de limiter donc il faut jamais
les limites ne soient franchies et on
peut se le dire même quand il ya des
ton qui monte avec beaucoup d'amitié et
donc la parenthèse est fermé et pour
julien houde président du groupe
rassemblement national au conseil
régional de bourgogne franche comté la
réaction des manuels macron était une
mise en scène c'est de la comédie mais
c'est vrai que c'est un bien piètre
acteur il veut nous faire une chirac
mais un petit peu pauvre le seul souci
c'est qu'on le voit dans cette séquence
il n'y a aucune spontanéité tout et
surjouée ya aucune sincérité d'ailleurs
mails mâcon qui parle très bien
l'anglais d'habitude on le voit il peut
faire un discours sans le moindre accent
là il force son accent français
donc pour rappeler évidemment le
l'épisode de 96 de jacques chirac et moi
ce que je déplore et ce qui est quand
même dangereux c'est qu'en faisant ça
donc que tout ça est calculé il fait un
clin d'oeil aux communautaristes en
france qui sont évidemment antisémites
qui sont hostiles à l'état d'israël
je trouve ça dangereux puisque lui dans
son et en même temps il fait cette
séquence
et puis condamne évidemment
l'antisionisme donc dans un discours
tout cela évidemment n'a aucun sens le
procès historique de donald trump vient
de débuter à washington avec l ouverture
des débats au sénat guerre sans surprise
le sénat à majorité républicaine a
rejeté toutes les propositions des
démocrates
le président américain est accusé
d'avoir exercé des pressions sur son
homologue ukrainien à vélines ski pour
contrer son rival pour la présidentielle
joe biden à washington les détails de
notre envoyé spécial de raadt elle
radiologues et bien ça y est on est
entré dans le vif du sujet après une
journée éprouvante hier l'accusation est
en ce moment en train de détail et de
présenter les faits qui sont reprochés à
donald trump alors c'est le démocrate
adam schiff le procureur en chef de ce
procès en destitution du président
américain qui a pris la parole en
premier donald trump est accusé de
d'abus de pouvoir et dont trava la bonne
conduite du congrès dans la sphère
ukrainienne et dès l'ouverture des
débats
adam schiff a accusé le président
américain de tricher le président trump
a bloqué des centaines de milles
de dollars d'aidé militaire à un
partenaire stratégique en guerre contre
la russie pour obtenir une aide
étrangère lors de sa réélection
hénart en d'autres termes pour tricher
enel souhaitent
de cette façon le président a utilisé
les pouvoirs officiels de l'état dont il
disposait et qui n'était disponible à
aucun opposant politique pour se donner
un avantage lors d'un scrutin
démocratique stratagème a été entrepris
pour la raison simple mais perverse de
l'aider à se faire réélire en 2020 pas
mais ce stratagème a eu pour effet de
fragiliser nos élections libres et
équitables et de mettre en danger notre
sécurité nationale alors adam schiff et
toujours au moment où je vous parle
à la tribune il est en train de de
détail est en fait tous les éléments
recueillis pendant l' enquête qui l'a
supervisé pendant plus de trois mois
puis son équipe qui est composée de six
élus démocrates ils font également
le rôle de procureurs vont se succéder à
la tribune pour convaincre les sénateurs
de la culpabilité de donald trump dans
cette affaire le craignait il faut
savoir qu'ils ont 24 heures de temps de
parole à répartir sur trois jours puis
ça sera au tour de la défense ne
s'organise et ils ont également le même
temps de parole à savoir 24 heures sur
trois jours pour et bien tout simplement
présenter leurs arguments et défendre
donald trump alors pour les démocrates
c'est vrai que ce procès est perdue
d'avancé
on le sait le sénat est majoritairement
républicain mais l'objectif ici est
surtout de convaincre l'opinion publique
américaine qui serait dangereux de
réélire un tel président vous le savez
les élections vont bientôt avoir lieu
dans dix mois précisément
alors certes hier soir ils ont échoué
devant le sénat pour obtenir
justement la convocation de témoins clés
à venir témoigner lors de ce procès en
destitution
mais ils vont sûrement revenir à la
charge dans les prochains jours et pour
anthony brian logan blogueurs politiques
américains cette procédure de
destitution est en réalité un moyen pour
les démocrates d'accéder à la présidence
aux prochaines élections en se
débarrassant du candidat sortant
si la destitution continue alors la
procédure sera utilisé à chaque sac il y
a des accords politiques
il pourrait être utilisé la prochaine
phase iib un démocrate aussi été élu
comme président les handicaps pour
essayer de se débarrasser de lui via la
destitution
elle te procédure est vraiment détourné
c'est un embarras cement je pense que
les démocrates n'ont personne qui puisse
devenir président en 2020 hillary
clinton en 2016 était plus forte
à l'époque que tous les candidats
démocrates aujourd'hui et pourtant elle
a perdu la processus la procédure de
destitution est donc juste un moyen
d'essayer de se débarrasser du président
parce qu'ils n'ont aucun autre ressort
beaucoup quoi qu'ils fassent n'ont pas
gagné donc ça ils se rabattent sur des
choses comme cela il n'y a aucun risque
qu'il perde son poste il faudrait que
vingt sénateurs votent en faveur d'un
retrait du président cela n'arrivera pas
les états unis la destination rêvée de
plusieurs centaines de migrants venus
d'amérique centrale ils ont été refoulés
hier par le mexique
ils ont improvisé un camp fortune à la
frontière avec le guatemala françois
christian beach sur les bords du fleuve
sushi hâter le réveil est difficile
la veille plusieurs centaines de
migrants tenté de traverser cette
frontière naturelle entre le guatemala
et le mexique avant de se heurter au gaz
lacrymogène des gardes nationaux
mexicain pour être honnête on
s'attendait pas à ce que le gouvernement
mexicain réagisse de cette façon parce
que nous sommes des êtres humains nous
ne sommes pas des animaux
nous avons des enfants avec nous mais
hier rien et tout cela n'avait
d'importance ces migrants
majoritairement hondurien et
guatémaltèques font partie d'une
caravane comptant plus de 3000 personnes
déterminé à rejoindre des états unis
plusieurs centaines d'entre eux avaient
déjà tenté en vain samedi d'entrer
illégalement au mexique le ministre
mexicain de l'intérieur avait alors
averti qu'aucun laissez-passer ne leur
serait remis une fermeté réitéré ce
mardi et à la liait au groupe pour le
mieux hier un groupe de 1000 personnes a
tenté d'entrer dans le pays par la force
ses rythmes une tragédie a été évitée
car il peut toujours y avoir de nombreux
problèmes surtout quand il ya des femmes
et des enfants
il faut être prudent et aujourd'hui nous
espérons que la prudence et le bon sens
prévale chez ceux qui dirigent ces
mouvements il y aura une action
essentielle raisonnables et prudentes
mais parce que nous devons respecter un
cadre juridique
parti mardi dernier de la ville de san
pedro sula dans le nord du honduras
cette caravane est la première depuis la
signature début juin d'un accord
migratoire entre mexico et washington
donald trump avait menacé de taxes
douanières le mexique si son voisin du
sud ne parvenait pas à bloquer le
passage de migrants le président
mexicain andré
manuel lopez obrador avait alors décidé
l'envoi de 21 mille gardes nationaux aux
frontières nord et sud du pays
un nouvelle manifestation anti système
en ce début de soirée au liban après
trois mois de crise le pays a depuis
hier un nouveau gouvernement validée par
le président michel aoun est dirigé par
le premier ministre hassan diab
mais les libanais qui peinent à être
convaincus ont à nouveau manifesté dans
les rues de beyrouth et précision de
cheryl benavides bullion la contestation
perdure dans plusieurs villes du pays
après l'annoncé du nouveau gouvernement
libanais ce mardi les manifestants
dénoncent les ministres fraîchement
désigné comme appartenant au même parti
que ceux du gouvernement précédent le
nouveau premier ministre
hassan diab universitaire et ancien
ministre de l'éducation a dû tenir sa
première réunion ce mercredi matin
avertissant que son pays au bord de la
faillite faisait face à une catastrophe
selon une déclaration lue par un haut
fonctionnaire
nous sommes face à une impasse
financière économique et sociale
en réalité nous sommes face à une
catastrophe et nous devons alléger
l'impact et les répercussions de cette
catastrophe sur les libanais la
description du problème peut nous
prendre beaucoup de temps maintenant
mais les intitulés des problèmes sont
claires et je suis sûr que chacun
d'entre vous comprend l'ampleur des
risques des groupes de manifestants ont
barré les rues avec des pneus en feu
dans plusieurs quartiers de beyrouth
détente brûler des manifestants
repoussés par les forces de l'ordre avec
des canons à eau et des gaz lacrymogènes
des scènes de guérilla urbaine preuve de
la détermination de la rue en tant que
manifestants si le gouvernement donne le
coup d'envoi nous resteront
définitivement dans la rue et il y aura
certainement une escalade car nous ne
pouvons pas nous laisser faire face à
cette situation la famine frappe aux
portes de toulouse la pauvreté et la
crise financière l'asphyxient traverse
tous pays nous nous mobiliserons de plus
en plus dans que le gouvernement ne nous
écoutera pas le liban connaît une des
pires crises socio économique et
financière depuis la fin de la guerre
civile en 1990 depuis le 17 octobre
dernier
l'ensemble de la classe dirigeante est
accusé de corruption et d'incompétence
des attaques qui avaient poussé l'ex
premier ministre saad hariri a
démissionné et pour paula rebels qui
vivent sainement du mouvement beyrouth
madinaty ce nouveau gouvernement est
contraire aux revendications de la rue
ce nouveau cabinet a été formée d'une
manière complètement égoïste on va dire
ils ont fait ce cabinet pour faire
plaisir à leurs propres partis ils ont
exclu certains partis et ils ont exclu
les demandes de la rue ils ont
complètement fait fi de la rue c'est
presque un défi pour nous
je ne sais pas ce qu'il apprend de
penser que le peuple est satisfait vous
voyez bien vous voyez vous même les
images que vous avez filmé c'est
insoutenable
ils sont en train d'attaquer les gens
les manifestants d'une manière qui ne
qui n'a rien à voir avec les droits de
l'homme il ya des distances pour les
balles en caoutchouc qui sont de 35
mètres minimum ils sont en train de
tirer à trois mètres nous avons plus de
500 blessés depuis le week end je dis
nous je parle de tout le peuple libanais
que ce soit forces de l'ordre aux
manifestants
le peuple a faim le peuple n'a pas les
moyens de payer son loyer nous voyons de
plus en plus de familles descendre
habiter dans la rue il veut pas payer
les écoles ce n'est pas un gouvernement
d'une seule coalition qui va pouvoir
régler cette crise en france le trafic à
la ratp
la sncf a été quasiment normale ce
mercredi mais la contestation contre la
réforme des retraites elle se poursuit à
deux jours de la grande mobilisation
attendue vendredi plusieurs opérations
ont eu lieu à travers toute la france
guillemard aussi rond 7 heures du matin
un rassemblement organisé par
l'intersyndicale tourner court
une centaine de manifestants tentent de
mettre en place un barrage filtrant dans
le cadre d'une opération ville morte
délogés par les forces de l'ordre ils se
dirigent ensuite vers la préfecture
une nouvelle action est prévue ce jeudi
plus au nord la grève des salariés de la
centrale nucléaire de gravelines près de
dunkerque se poursuit ces derniers ont
reçu la visite du secrétaire général de
la cgt philippe martinez venus re
motiver les agents qui depuis près de
deux semaines filtrent les entrées du
site
s'il fallait une démonstration ce cette
lutte
cette mobilisation elle est massive et
populaire vous en fait la démonstration
par le nombre qui est rassemblée ici et
par ce qui se passe dans cette centrale
vous le savez le gouvernement essaye de
nous dire que cette réforme est juste et
simple elle est tellement elle est
tellement simple que personne n'y
comprend rien elle est tellement juste
qu'il ya des milliers des dizaines de
milliers de salariés qui sont en grains
dans ce pays et que plus de 60% de
l'opinion publique soutient massivement
mais mouvant gravel mouvement social qui
est en cours depuis le 5 décembre de
l'année dernière
la cgt qui a relancé ce mercredi
l'opération port mort au havre mais
aussi dans la cité phocéenne
le grand port de marseille connaît
régulièrement des blocages depuis le
mois de décembre
seul moyen de se faire entendre selon
les agents portuaires et d'obtenir le
retrait du projet de réforme
le patronat doit aujourd'hui prendre
conscience qu'on se rattrapa et
continuera et que les impacts
aujourd'hui économique qui mesure bien
évidemment on allait confirmer on n'a
pas d'autre choix pour essayer d'être
entendu et c'est notre seul moyen
aujourd'hui de faire en sorte que le
gouvernement a bien revienne sur sa
décision avec ce projet de réforme des
retraites
enfin paris épicentre de la contestation
depuis le début du mouvement
outre un rassemblement de salariés du
commerce et des services devant la gare
saint lazare les égoutiers sont venus
exprimer leur mécontentement au pied du
ministère des finances à bercy
selon eux la réforme supprimerait les
avantages liés à la pénibilité de leur
profession
repoussant de dix ans leur départ en
retraite donc on a choisi le ministère
de l'économie et des finances
aujourd'hui pour montrer les victimes de
la réforme des retraites à savoir les
égoutiers avec la fin de la catégorie
active et de nos de notre statut
aujourd'hui avec l'espérance de vie de
17 ans réduite qu'on les égoutiers on
partira à la retraite et on sera mort
quotidiennement un égoutier l'exposer à
des insectes à deraa des plus vous
pouvez les pieds dans la merde quand
vous tirez votre chasse d'eau les
écuries et mange dedans on l'a retrouvée
de l'amiante maintenant appellation de
notre dame à tous et duplo
quotidiennement un égoutier l'exposé
sarrassat et maintenant on nous dit qu
on dit on casse le système maintenant
c'est 60 de son ballon ça on ne se
retrouve pas en équipe et sait on à 10
58 ans d'espérance de vie des actions
qui doivent se poursuivre en cette fin
de semaine avec en point d'orgue une
vaste mobilisation prévue dans toute la
france vendredi à l'appel de
l'intersyndicale pourrait stopper les
violences des forces de l'ordre contre
les journalistes c'est le but du code de
la liberté de la presse pour la police
un code établi par le centre européen
pour la liberté de la presse et des
médias qui arrivent en france plusieurs
syndicats et associations de
journalistes ont présenté aujourd'hui à
paris mathilde romagne andrea le
bourgeois avec cynthia lauvergeon gilet
jaune grève contre la réforme des
retraites des conflits sociaux que les
journalistes doivent couvrir sur le
terrain depuis un an et demi les
incidents avec les forces de l'ordre
sont de plus en plus nombreux lors des
manifestations pour y remédier les
syndicats snj et snj cgt veulent adopter
le code de la liberté de la presse en
huit points il essaie de poser les bases
de bonnes relations entre journalistes
et forces de l'ordre en grosse les
permettre aux journalistes de bien faire
leur travail c'est à dire
que quand ils sont signalés les journaux
les policiers constatent qu'ils sont
bien journalistes et donc contre les
embête pas évidemment l'interdiction
pour la police de saisir notre matériel
parce que beaucoup de reporter de
journaliste reporter d'image ont vu leur
matériel saisi par la police expliqué à
la police qu est un journaliste ou
simplement qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
journaliste avec une carte de presse et
caetera voilées des des choses toutes
simples dont on a l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui même ceux là ce n'est
plus possible en france un texte rédigé
par le centre européen pour la liberté
de la presse et des médias
sa porte-parole juge la situation dans
l'hexagone préoccupante
il y a des incidences calment grave où
les journalistes ont été interpellés
avec violence ont été blessées à paris
après son sens ap ap les forces de
l'ordre continuent il n'y a pas de dents
quête il n'y a pas d'eau
publicité partout dans les médias et de
l'appât de la police c'est cette jeune
homme
les syndicats déplorent l'absence de
dialogue avec la police le snj cgt
affirme avoir envoyé un courrier au
ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner pour engager une discussion sur
le sujet mais sans réponse ce code est
rédigé en collaboration avec eurocop la
confédération européenne de la police je
trouve que c'est un bon début pour
ouvrir un dialogue sur
l'agression de sur les journalistes et
aussi pour montrer que c'est une
histoire de deux côtés pas seulement le
côté des journalistes mais aussi le côté
des policiers
reporters sans frontières a recensé 120
incidents dont 88 majeur ainsi que 54
journalistes blessés
en six mois de mobilisation des gilet
jaune en novembre dernier 13
journalistes ont porté plainte contre x
en compagnie de rsf pour dénoncer les
violences policières dont ils font
l'objet
et pour pablo et qu'elle secrétaire à la
vie syndicale du bureau national du snj
cgt il ya encore du chemin à faire avant
la mise en place de solutions concrètes
des solutions concrètes
aujourd'hui c'est difficile tant qu'il
n'y a pas de dialogue de vrais dialogues
où les gens s'écoute sont tendres et
aujourd'hui en france ce dialogue et
n'existe pas on n'a pas de réponses ou
des réponses un peu à côté de la plaque
de la part du gouvernement et avec les
syndicats de police évidemment il n'ya
il y a aujourd'hui pas de dialogue ce
qui est intéressant c'est s'il ya une
solution
le représentant de la police
belge qui qui est aussi délégué de rekop
le disait s'il n'y a pas de dialogue
c'est difficile de trouver des solutions
et dans d'autres pays un petit peu en
allemagne mais déjà aux pays bas un peu
plus il montre que les échanges la
formation croisée que les journalistes
soient formés au travail de la police
que les policiers soient formés en
travail des journalistes
ce sont des solutions intéressantes mais
je pense que nous on est très loin et
qu'un premier pas serait de le renvoyer
ce code de la liberté de la presse pour
la police aux préfets dans les
départements ain au ministère aux
syndicats de policiers pour qu'on
commence à se parler parce que le
constat est difficile et luigi di maio
démissionne du mouvement 5 étoiles qu'il
présidait annonce faite cet après midi
lors d'un rassemblement de membres du
mouvement est cette décision intervient
juste avant une élection régionale
cruciale prévue dimanche dans le
nord-est du pays
une victoire de l'extrême droite qui
pourrait entraîner la chute du
gouvernement formé par le mouvement de
cinq étoiles et le parti démocrate ont
l'écoutent
je suis ici aujourd'hui pour donner ma
démission en tant que leader du
mouvement 5 étoiles et ouvrir la route
vers le congrès du parti
beaucoup d'entre vous m'écrivent et
m'appellent pour me dire de ne pas
abandonner
je n'abandonne pas
en ce qui me concerne ce n'est que la
fin d'une phase et nous nous reverrons
au congrès du parti
nous pourrons échanger des idées je
serai là pour l'italie et pour tous ceux
qui ont besoin d aide
je serai là et je n'abandonnerai pas
pour ma part je continuerai à servir les
italiens et le mouvement 5 étoiles en
faisant le plus d'efforts possibles
entre autres choses nous avons un
référendum constitutionnel en mai un
autre objectif que nous avons atteint
[Applaudissements]
pour moi et pour vous une nouvelle
saison va commencer à partir de ce soir
où rôle de chef de parti cessera je vous
remercie
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain rendez vous ce
sera demain avec l'actualité à 7 heures
du matin heure française
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui pousse tout simplement un
apnéiste à vouloir toucher les abîmes
le but ultime c'est pas forcément de
gagner des médailles welsh podium c'est
d'arriver à gérer ses émotions dans un
certain environnement et c'est un
univers qui nous permet justement
d'aller encore plus loin dans cet état
d'introspection et de travail sur le
corps et aussi sur l'esprit plus on va
être dans l'instant prêt